THE ASSEMBLY IS
NOW IN SESSION. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRASIER NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF
A QUORUM THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS
WILL PREPARE THE CHAMBER BRING
IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE
CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL.
DEGREE ARE CURSED. ARAMBULA OUR
QUE HAN BENNETT BERMAN BIGELOW
BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH BONTA
BURKE CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES CHAU CHEN CHIU CHOI
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY
DAILY DAVIES FLORA FONG. EASTER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KILEY BLACKY LIII LEVINE LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN QUINN
O'DONNELL. SEN PETRIE-NORRIS
QUIRK QUIRK SILVA RAMOS RADIUS
THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO
SAY ARTURO SMITH STONE TEAM
CALAVERAS BE APPROVED VIA
VOEPEL WALDRON WARD WICKS WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT IN THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER. AND IN THE
GALLERY. TO PLEASE STAND FOR
THE PRAYER. THE DAYS PRAYER
WILL BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN IMAM YASIR KHAN IMAM
YES SIR. IN THE NAME OF GOD.
THE MOST GRACIOUS THE MOST
MERCIFUL. THIS TODAY. WE ASK
THAT YOU GUIDE US TO LET OUR
WORDS AND ACTIONS BRING LIFE.
TO THOSE AROUND US. HELP US-
GOD TO FOCUS MORE ON LOVING
PEOPLE THAN PROVING OUR POINT.
LORD WE SEEK YOUR FORGIVENESS
FOR ANY ATTITUDES WE HAVE THAT
ARE UNPLEASANT TO YOU. USE US
AS A CATALYST TO BRING HOPE JOY
AND ENCOURAGEMENT TO OTHERS. I
MEAN. THANK YOU MA'AM YES SIR
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
TO REMAIN STANDING JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE. PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE MISTER
MATHIS. THANK YOU SPEAKER
MEMBERS READY SALUTE. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. WHICH
IS. THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL. THE GERMAN SACRAMENTO
WEDNESDAY MARCH TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE ASSEMBLY
MINUTE SEVEN AM THE AUDIBLE
ELOISE GOMEZ REYES ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FORTY SEVEN JUST
PRESIDING TO FOLKS WHO PROGRESS
THE DESPERATE FOR DAVID BOWMAN
READING THE FOLLOWING REPLACED
ON THE MORNING ROLL CALL
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA ABOUT THE
HAND BEEN IT BERMAN BIGELOW
BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH BURKE.
TOLD RAMOS MOVES AND MISS
WALDRON SECONDS THAT THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS HAVE PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE. INTRODUCTION
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE. THERE ARE NONE.
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THE
ABSENCES FOR THE DAY FOR
PERSONAL BUSINESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PHILLIP CHEN FOR ILLNESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA
AS WELL ASSEMBLY MEMBER. S.
HOLDINGS. MOVING TO PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS. THIS RACE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE. ONE ONE EIGHT EIGHT TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE TO
HAVE HER DAUGHTER SEATED AT HER
DESK. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SIX AND
SIXTY THREE TO WITHDRAW SB
EIGHTY FIVE SB EIGHTY SIX AND
THE S. B. NINETY THREE FROM THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE AND ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEAM TO TAKE
THEM UP TODAY WITHOUT REFERENCE
TO FILE FOR THE PURPOSE OF
THIRD READING. MR FLOOR FOR
PURPOSE SIR THE MISTER SPEAKER
WITHHOLDING ELSE CONSENT MUST
RECALL THE- EVERS MISTER FLOOR
IS WITHHOLDING MS REYES MOVES
MR BONTA SECONDS. ON THE RULES
SUSPENSION MEMBERS THIS IS A
PROCEDURAL VOTE. THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE IS RADIUS IS
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE AND MR
FLORA KNOW ABOUT HIS RACE IS
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE. MISTER
FLOOR I KNOW THIS IS A
PROCEDURAL VOTE. THIS IS
PROCEDURAL. CLARK WELL CLOSER
ALL EYES FORTY EIGHT KNOWS
FOURTEEN THE RULES ARE
SUSPENDED. MS REYES MISTER
SPEAKER PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE NINETY SIX I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE REFER
THE FOLLOWING BILLS TO
COMMITTEE. AB FOUR FORTY EIGHT
MAYES FROM THE NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE TO THE
UTILITIES AND ENERGY COMMITTEE
AND THEN BACK TO NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE. AB FIVE OH
SIX GONZALEZ FROM THE INSURANCE
COMMITTEE TO THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE. AB NINE FIVE THREE
KILEY FROM THE PRIVACY AND
CONSUMER PROTECTION COMMITTEE
TO THE WATER PARKS AND WILDLIFE
COMMITTEE. AB THIRTEEN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN FROM THE HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE
TO THE AGING AND LONG TERM CARE
COMMITTEE. AB THIRTEEN FORTY
FOUR ARAMBULA FROM THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE TO THE NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE AND THE AB
FIFTEEN THIRTY ONE O'DONNELL
FROM THE NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE TO THE UTILITIES AND
ENERGY COMMITTEE AND THEN BACK
TO THE NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO BE
MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY
FILE. SECOND READING CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN ONE FOUR TWO EIGHTY TWO
TO FORTY TWO WITH A MEMBERS AND
FIFTY EIGHT WITH A MEMBER SIX
NINETEEN OF THE MOMENT SEVENTY
WITH A MEMBERS LEVIN A FORMER
MEMBERS FORCIBLY SETTLE THE
MEMBERS TWENTY TO THE MINUTES.
THIRTEEN SIXTY THREE WITH A
MINISTRY TWENTY TO THE MOMENT
SEVEN THREE WITH A MEMBERS A
FORTY THREE BY THE MEMBERS THE
SIX MOMENTS ONE TEN WITH THE
WOMEN'S THIRTEEN NINETY ONE OF
THE MEMBERS FOURTEEN THIRTY
SIX. ASSEMBLY REAL FIFTEEN
FORTY FIVE OF THE MEMBERS
INNOCENTLY. CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION SIXTY TWO THE MENACE.
ALL BILLS WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE HAVE. SOME BUDGET
ITEMS TO TAKE UP. WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE. THIS IS
SENATE BILL. EIGHTY FIVE. THE
CLERK WILL READ. SENATE BILL
EIGHTY FIVE BY THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET FISCAL
REVIEW AND ACCOLADES THE STATE
BUDGET MAKING APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BUDGET BILL.
MEMBERS. PLEASE DIRECT YOUR
ATTENTION TO MR TAKE MR TANG
YOU MAY OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I AM PROUD TO PRESENT
SB EIGHTY FIVE WHICH IS OUR
WILDFIRE EARLY ACTION PROPOSAL
AT A TIME WHEN MANY SCIENTISTS
ARE TALKING ABOUT HOW THIS IS
ONE OF THE DRIEST YEARS EVER.
WE'VE HAD A STRING OF YEARS
WHERE WE'VE HAD. CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES THE WATER OF WILDFIRE
THIS IS A VERY SIGNIFICANT
EARLY INVESTMENT. IN MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE DOING. FORCE
RESILIENCY PROJECTS ****
WILDFIRE PREVENTION IN A WHOLE
HOST. OF OTHER PROPOSALS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE DOING
EVERY PART. THIS IS THE ONLY
THE ONLY OPTION PROPOSAL WE
ANTICIPATE DOING EVEN MORE. IN
THIS YEAR'S UPCOMING BUDGET. OF
THE APPROPRIATION IS A FIVE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SIX MILLION
TOTAL FUNDING FOR THESE
PROJECTS. MANY OF THESE
INVESTMENTS ARE. ACTUAL SHOVEL
READY PROJECTS ARE READY. TO
HAVE AN IMMEDIATE IMPACT THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO THAT
RIGHT NOW FOR A FULL TIME TAKE
ACTION AND TO GET AHEAD. OF
THIS SUMMER AND THIS FALL.
THERE ALSO ARE SOME TECHNICAL
CHANGES FOR SUPPORT FOR
RESOURCE FAMILIES IN FOSTER
CARE AND A COUPLE OTHER.
AGAINST TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE ON SB EIGHTY FIVE.
THANK YOU MISTER TANK MR FONG
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. I THANK YOU
MR SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHTY FIVE. WE
ARE ANTICIPATING ANOTHER
POTENTIALLY VERY BAD WILD FIRE
SEASON. WE ALL REMEMBER THE
INCREDIBLE TOLL AND DEVASTATION
OF PRIOR YEARS IN WHICH SO MANY
FAMILIES WERE DEVASTATED DUE TO
OUT OF CONTROL WILDFIRES. OUR
FORESTS ARE FILLED WITH DEAD
AND DYING TREES WE HAVE AGING
UTILITY INFRASTRUCTURE AND A
HARSH DROUGHT WILL CRIPPLE OUR
ABILITY TO KEEP OUR COMMUNITY
SAFE. FROM DEADLY WILDFIRES YOU
MUST UTILIZE EVERY PROVEN
WILDFIRE PREVENTION TOOL IN
MITIGATION TACTIC. TO REPAIR
FOR THE SEASON SB EIGHTY FIVE
GETS US IN A BETTER POSITION TO
COMBAT THE IMPENDING WILDFIRE
SEASON. COMMITMENTS MADE IN SB
NINE OH ONE GUARANTEED FUNDING
TOWARDS IMPROVING FOREST HEALTH
AND CRITICAL FUEL REDUCTION
PROJECTS. AND TODAY. WE ARE
HOLDING TRUE TO THAT COMMITMENT.
WE MUST CAN THIS FUNDING FOR.
FUTURE YEARS A FORCE MANAGEMENT
AS WE MOVE FORWARD I URGE AN
AYE VOTE ON SB EIGHTY FIVE.
THANK YOU MR FONG MR BLOOM YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND I WANT TO THANK-
OUR BUDGET YOU'RE ON A BUDGET
VICE CHAIR FOR THEIR WORK ON
THIS AS WELL AS- THE WORKING
GROUP FIVE SPEAKER STAFF- THIS
WAS REALLY A COLLECTIVE EFFORT-
IT'S NOTEWORTHY FOR A COUPLE OF
REASONS ONE IS. WE'RE REALLY
DOUBLING DOWN ON THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY THAT WE ARE MAKING
AVAILABLE TO SPEND ON
PREVENTION. THIS IS- RIGHT NOW
FIVE HUNDRED AND THIRTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS. LAST YEAR IN
THE DEVASTATING. OCCUPIERS OF-
THAT WE'RE STATE WIDE IF YOU
LOOK AT THE MAP THEY WERE FROM
ONE END TO THE STATE TO THE
OTHER IN OVER FOUR. POINT FOUR
MILLION ACRES BURNED IN THE
STATE. WE SPENT NINE BILLION
DOLLARS FIGHTING THOSE FIRES WE
TAKE AWAY NOTHING FROM THE
FIREFIGHTING EFFORT THAT WILL
HAPPEN IN THE FUTURE WE KNOW
THEY'RE GOING TO BE FIRES BUT
WE NEED TO START DOING
PREVENTION WORK. AND THIS IS A
DOWN PAYMENT IT GETS US STARTED.
IT'S ALSO NOTEWORTHY BECAUSE
WE'RE DOING IT EARLY WE'RE
DOING IT NOW THE MONEY THAT
WE'RE- HOPEFULLY GOING TO
APPROVE TODAY WILL START TO
FLOW VIRTUALLY IMMEDIATELY AND
THE AGENCIES AND FOLKS WHO
WERE. GOING TO PUT IN A REQUEST
FOR THIS MONEY ARE READY TO ACT
AND START ROLLING OUT THEIR
EFFORTS ALMOST IMMEDIATELY.
CALIFORNIA IS THE SOURCES OF-
OF WILDFIRES IN CALIFORNIA- ARE
AS DIVERSE AS THE STATE ITSELF.
AND SO ONE OTHER IMPORTANT
WITH THIS PREVENTION EFFORT IS
THAT THE EARLY ACTION AND
HOPEFULLY FUTURE ACTIONS WILL
TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION THE
REGIONAL FIRE PREVENTION NEEDS
ADDRESSING DIFFERENT PREVENTION
METHODS FOR. EXAMPLE WIN FUEL
CHAPARRAL FIRES THAT WE SEE IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA VERSUS. THE
TYPES OF FIRES THAT WE SEE IN
THE SIERRAS WHERE THEY ARE
VEGETARIAN VEGETATION FUELED. I
AND- MOVE THROUGH TOWERING
DRIVE FOR US. THE EARLY BUDGET
ACTION INCREASES CREWS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE TO CAL FIRE IT
PROVIDES MONEY FOR HOME
HARDENING FOR OLDER HOMES FIRE
PREVENTION GRANTS AND FIRE
PREVENTION FUNDING FOR THE
STATE'S CONSERVANCY'S. IN THE
YEAR WERE COMING OFF THIS
DEADLY WILDFIRE SEASON FACED
WITH DROUGHT LIKE CONDITIONS
RIGHT NOW AND RECORD LOW
RAINFALL RECORD HIGH
TEMPERATURES PLANTS AND TREES
AROUND THE STATE ARE VERY
STRESSED RESULTING IN DRIER AND
MORE DANGEROUS CONDITIONS. THEN
THIS STATE HAS EVER SEEN THIS
FUNDING COULD NOT COME AT A
MORE CRUCIAL TIME AND I HOPE
YOU'LL JOIN ME IN SUPPORTING
THIS LIFESAVING EARLY BUDGET
ACTION. THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM
MISTER RODRIGUEZ YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
MEMBERS ARE RISING SUPPORT OF
THIS IMPORTANT BUDGET MEASURE
AS CHAIR OF THE MERTON TO
MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE WE HAVE TO
BE READY ARE MERGED TO RESPOND
AS A SYSTEMS NEED TO BE READY
UP AND DOWN THE STATE AND
CALIFORNIANS NEED TO BE READY
AT THEIR HOMES AND PLACES OF
WORK. THE THREE HUNDRED FORTY
SIX MILLION FOR CALIFORNIA
BEGIN THIS CRITICAL WORK OF
PREPARING OUR COMMUNITIES NOW
CAN'T WAIT ARBITRATE SYSTEMS
WILL BE TESTED YET AGAIN THIS
SUMMER AND TODAY WE HAVE A
CHANCE TO SUPPORT THEM EARLY SO
THOSE AND MANY OTHER REASONS I
SUPPORT A. B. EIGHTY FIVE THANK
U. S. B. THANK YOU MISS
RODRIGUEZ. MR FRAZIER. YOUR
ADDRESS. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER SO OBVIOUSLY I DO
SUPPORT THIS BILL BECAUSE I
KIND OF AND- DID TEN BILLS ARE
ON THE SUBJECT MATTER THIS YEAR
AND WANTED TO BE PART OF THIS
EQUATION THE IT ELLEN YOU FIRE
WAS WITHIN A MILE AND A HALF OF
MY HOUSE. AND WE INTEGRATED-
ALL OF THE YOU KNOW-
STAKEHOLDERS AND ALL OF THE-
EXPERTS SO WE CAN DO OVER THE
LAST SIX OR SEVEN MONTHS WITH
MY STAFF. WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS INVESTMENT IS VERY
PRESCRIPTIVE IN HAS EXPECTED
OUTCOMES ARE UNDERSTANDING THAT
WE HAVE BEEN DEFICIENT OR OUR
DILIGENCE ON WILDFIRE COMING UP
TO THIS POINT THE LAST THREE
YEARS HAVE BEEN DEVASTATING NOT
ONLY TO. THE ECONOMY BUT A LOSS
OF LIFE AND PROPERTY DAMAGE I
THINK THE INSURANCE INDUSTRY IN
THE LAST FIRE LOST ABOUT TEN
BILLION DOLLARS WHEN. MY- ALI
FROM SANTA MONICA SAID SAID.
THE- YOU KNOW TEN NINE NINE
BILLION IN LOSS OF ALSO SO IT
ITS ONGOING IT HAS A
MULTIPLYING AFFECTED MOST MOST
PEOPLE ONE OF THE THINGS I'D
LIKE TO BRING TO LIGHT THOUGH
IS WHEN WE LOOK AT ALL OF THE
EFFORTS NO MINE HAD A BIGGER
COMPONENT OF GIGI R. F. OF.
FUNDING AND THE REASON BEING IS
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
NINETEENTH. OR THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WILDFIRE THAT WE HAD.
IT EMITTED SIXTY EIGHT MILLION
METRIC TONS OF CARBON. OKAY THE
CONTINUATION OF THE LAST THREE
FIRES HAVE BEEN OVER TWO
HUNDRED MILLION METRIC TONS OF
CARBON EMITTED. THAT IN ITSELF
IS NEGATED EVERYTHING THE CARB
IS DONE WITH THE G. G. R. UP
FUND. THEY'VE ONLY BEEN ABLE TO
ATTAIN AND IF IT'S A LOT OF
WILL GO IN IS FANTASTIC THEY
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO. BUT THEY'VE
ONLY IT. BEEN ABLE TO. CAPTURE
A LIMON A FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE
MILLION METRIC TONS. FOR TWELVE
AND A HALF BILLION DOLLARS. NOW
AGAIN LAUDABLE GOALS BUT I
THINK THAT WE NEED TO TAKE THIS
IS A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. AND PUT MORE
PRIORITY ON WILDFIRE MITIGATION
SUPPRESSION FORCED THE
MANAGEMENT HOME HARDENING. AND
GET AHEAD OF THIS WITH THE GOOD
WORK THE CARD DOES CAN ACTUALLY
MEANS SOMETHING AND ACTUALLY.
BE SOMETHING THAT ACTUALLY
COUNTS THAT'S WHAT I'M LOOKING
FOR IS WE NEED TO. ROB FROM
PETER TO PAY PAUL RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE THIS IS A DEVASTATING
EFFECT THAT HAS HAPPENED. I'M
JUST HOPING THAT WE CAN GO
FORWARD MAKE THIS IS A NATIONAL
INVESTMENT THE REALIZE THAT WE
HAVE TO CAPTURE. MORE CARBON
THIS WAY SO THAT THE OTHER CAN
BE AFFECTED THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISS FRAZIER DOCTOR WHAT
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AS THE
MEMBER WHO'S THAT HAD- THREE OF
THE FIVE LARGEST WILDFIRES IN
THE HISTORY OF CALIFORNIA BURN
IN MY DISTRICT I STAND IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL TWO OF
THOSE. FIRES WERE LAST YEAR.
THIS DEAL INCLUDES TWO HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY MILLION DOLLARS
THAT OPPOSE THE ANNUAL FUNDING
COMMITMENT I REQUESTED ALONG
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER DOLLY AT
THE TIME. THREE YEARS AGO IN SB
NINE A ONE IT ALSO DEDICATES
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO
HOOK FUND HOME HARDING EFFORTS
IS LAID OUT IN MY BILL AB
THIRTY EIGHT. WHICH WAS SIGNED
TWO YEARS AGO AND IS LOCKED
FUNDING TO THE STATE BUDGET
CONSTRAINTS. THAT TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS WILL ALLOW US
TO SEEKS SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN MATCHING FEDERAL
FUNDS FROM FEMA. THE DEAL ALSO
INCLUDES FIFTY BILLION DOLLARS
IN REFINING FOR REGIONAL FOREST
AND FIRE CAPACITY PROGRAM IS
DESIGNED IN MY BILL INTRODUCED
THIS YEAR AB NINE. THE EARLY
ACTION WILL HELP US GET
CRITICAL FIRE PREVENTION WORK
UNDERWAY BEFORE THE HEART OF
THIS YEAR'S FIRE SEASON.
PREVENTION AND PREPAREDNESS IS
CRITICAL FOR BOTH STAVING LIVES
AS AS WELL AS A SOUND FINANCIAL
INVESTMENT. FEMA RESEARCH SHOWS
THAT FOR EVERY DOLLAR SPENT ON
PREVENTION WE SAVE SIX DOLLARS
ON CLEAN UP AND REBUILDING. THE
FIRE CRISES WE ARE WE ARE AND
WE ARE IN TOOK GENERATIONS TO
CORRECT CREATE IT WILL TAKE
DECADES TO SOLVE THIS CANNOT
END WE NEED ANOTHER BIG
COMMITMENT OF RESOURCES IN THE
JUNE BUDGET. WE'VE ALREADY LOST
MONTHS OF POSSIBLE PREPARE
PREPAREDNESS AND PREVENTION
WORK. AND WE'RE HEADING INTO
ANOTHER DROUGHT. WE NEED TO
PREPARE BE PREPARING FOR FIRE
SEASON LIKE WE ARE PREPARING
FOR AN IMPENDING HURRICANE.
JUST BECAUSE WE CAN'T SEE IT
BEARING DOWN ON US LIKE A
HURRICANE DOES. DOESN'T MEAN
THAT THE STORM IS ANY LESS REAL
AND THAT ISN'T COMING ONCE A
FIRE STARTS IT'S TOO LATE. THAT
PREPARATION WORK NEEDS TO
BEGINNING AND START HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU DR
WHAT IS WALDRON. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK. THANK
YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS ALL
RIGHTS TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB EIGHTY FIVE AS WE KNOW THIS
PAST YEAR WE'VE EXPERIENCED
SOME OF THE LARGEST WILDFIRES
IN CALIFORNIA HISTORY. THE
REGION I REPRESENT EXPERIENCE
TWO OF THE MOST DESTRUCTIVE
WILDFIRES IN THE LAST TWENTY
YEARS THE CEDAR FIRE IN TWO
THOUSAND THREE WHICH BURNED.
OVER TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY THREE
THOUSAND ACRES. ALMOST THREE
THOUSAND STRUCTURES WITH
FIFTEEN DEATHS THE WHICH FIRE
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN. WITH
ALMOST TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
ACRES BURNED AND SIXTEEN
HUNDRED FIFTY STRUCTURES INTO
THE- THESE NUMBERS THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY EXPERIENCE EXAMPLE
BY THE WILDFIRES ARE DEFINITELY
AN ISSUE. FOR THE ENTIRE STATE
BOTH NORTHERN AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA COMBINE. HELPING
VICTIMS SHOULD OF COURSE BE OUR
IMMEDIATE PRIORITY BUT WE MUST
DEVELOP POLICIES THAT WILL
PREVENT FUTURE MEGA FIRES. THE
THREAT OF WILDFIRES IS STILL
GROWING BY THE DAY IS MILLIONS
OF DEAD TREES ARE FILLING OUR
CARS WITH FUEL VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT IS STILL LACKING.
IT'S CERTAINLY COMMENDABLE WITH
THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION THAT
PROVIDES FIVE HUNDRED THIRTY
SIX. MILLION IN EARLY ACTION
WHILE FOR A FOREST RESILIENCE
FUNDING TO ENSURE THAT LIES THE
PROTECTIVE FROM THE FIRES THAT
PLAGUE OUR STATE EVERY YEAR.
ALTHOUGH I BELIEVE THAT WE AS
THE LEGISLATURE TO FOCUS MORE
ON PREVENTION ON FUEL REDUCTION.
FOREST MANAGEMENT PROJECTS AND
THE UNIQUE CHAPARRAL OAK
WOODLANDS OF OUR SOUTHERN
REGION THAT BEING SAID THIS
BILL IS DEFINITELY A STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION OF
PREVENTING WILDFIRES IN
CALIFORNIA- TO THE LEVEL.
BIGHAM IS WALDRON MR GALLAGHER
YOU'RE RECKONS. THANK YOU
MEMBERS- I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
SB EIGHTY FIVE TODAY BUT IF WE
THINK THAT THIS IS ENOUGH. TO
ADDRESS THE CRISIS THAT WE ARE
IN RIGHT NOW WHEN IT COMES TO
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRE WE ARE
FOOLING OURSELVES. AND WE EED
TO TALK ABOUT THE HISTORY A
LITTLE BIT HERE AND WHAT'S
REALLY IN THIS BILL FIVE FIVE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS GETS THROWN AROUND
THAT'S A BIG NUMBER. IT'S GOOD
TO TALK ABOUT THAT. LET'S TALK
ABOUT WHAT'S IN THAT FIVE
HUNDRED THIRTY SIX MILLION A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE MILLION
IS TO MEET THE OBLIGATION FROM
LAST YEAR. OF THE S. B. NINE OH
ONE COMPROMISE. WHICH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM HEALDSBURG AND
MY COLLEAGUE FROM BEAVER
SUCCESSFULLY NEGOTIATED THREE
YEARS AGO. BUT WE DID NOT PUT
THAT MONEY IN LAST YEAR. SO
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE MILLION OF
THIS IS JUST KEEPING OUR
COMMITMENT FROM LAST YEAR.
THAT'S NOT NEW ADDITIONAL
MONEY. ON THE TABLE TO ADDRESS
THIS. THE NEW ADDITIONAL MONEY
IN HERE IS ABOUT A HUNDRED
EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS. OF
GENERAL FUND MONEY TO DO WHAT I
WOULD CALL. FUEL REDUCTION OF
FORESTRY HEALTH PROJECTS THAT'S
WHAT IT'S REALLY ABOUT IT'S
REALLY ABOUT A HUNDRED EIGHTY
MILLION. NOT THAT THAT'S BAD
BUT IT'S NOT ENOUGH. I HAVE
LEGISLATION THIS YEAR THAT
WOULD DOUBLE. THAT TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR COMMITMENT A
YEAR WE SHOULD BE DOING THAT
RIGHT NOW NEED TO DOUBLE DOWN
NOW BECAUSE THE PROBLEM IS
ALREADY HONEST FIRES ARE
HAPPENING NOW. COMMUNITIES ARE
GETTING WIPED OUT NOW. PARADISE
IN MY DISTRICT VERY CREEK IN MY
COLLEAGUES DISTRICT. LAKE
COUNTY IN MY COLLEAGUES IN MY
COLLEAGUES DISTRICT FROM NAPA.
FAR TOO MANY COMMUNITIES HAVE
BEEN DEVASTATED BECAUSE WE'RE
NOT GETTING ON TOP OF THE FUEL
REDUCTION. ISSUE THE ISSUE IS
FUEL. WE HAVE TEN FOOT TALL
PILES OF BRUSH AND SOME OF
THESE AREAS IT DOESN'T MATTER
WHERE THIS PART COMES FROM.
WHEREVER IT COMES FROM IT'S A
CONFLAGRATION THAT OUR
FIREFIGHTERS SAY. THEY CAN'T
EVEN STOP IT ONCE IT STARTS IT
BECOMES A LIFESAVING MISSION
NOT A FIRE SUPPRESSION THAT
MISSION. SO IF YOU'RE NOT
GETTING ON TOP OF THE FUEL
REDUCTION IF YOU'RE NOT DOING
SOMETHING ABOUT FUEL YOU'RE NOT
SOLVING THIS PROBLEM. SO
HUNDRED EIGHTY HUNDRED EIGHTY
MILLION BUT THE REST OF IT IS A
LOT OF SMOKE AND MIRRORS. AND
LET'S FACE IT WE DON'T NEED
ANYMORE SMOKE. IN CALIFORNIA
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'VE HAD
MYCOLOGIST TALKED ABOUT THE
CARBON EMISSIONS FROM THESE
FIRES THEY- THEY COMPLETELY
DWARF. THE REDUCTIONS THAT
WE'VE MADE ON CARBON. AND STILL
WE JUST. WELL DOWN ON THE MONEY.
AND WE NEED TO REDUCE THE
BUREAUCRATIC. RED TAPE THE GETS
IN THE WAY OF DOING PROJECTS
SEEK WAS A PROBLEM SYKORA
STANDS IN THE WAY OF DOING
THESE PROJECTS WE DID THIRTY
FIVE UNDER THE GOVERNOR BECAUSE
THE GOVERNOR. PUSH FOR
STREAMLINED PROJECTS WE DID
THIRTY FIVE OF THEM. WE DON'T
KNOW HOW MANY MORE ARE GOING TO
BE DONE UNDER THIS BILL. THERE
STILL HAS BEEN NO STREAMLINING
THAT'S ANOTHER ISSUE THAT NEEDS
TO BE ADDRESSED. I HAVE
LEGISLATION ON THAT FRONT. THAT
I WOULD HOPE THAT THIS BODY
WOULD PASS BECAUSE IF YOU HAVE
THE MONEY. BUT YOU DON'T HAVE
THE ABILITY TO MOVE FOR WITH
THE PROJECT. WHICH IS EXACTLY
WHAT HAPPENED IN BERRY CREEK
THIS YEAR. THEY HAD THE MONEY.
PREPARE TO MOVE FOR THE
PROJECT. AND HOW TO DO A FULL
ANOTHER SEQUEL REVIEW AND IT.
PUT THEM OUT EIGHTEEN MONTHS
THE FIRE CAME THIS YEAR. IF WE
DON'T DO SOMETHING ABOUT
STREAMLINING SEEK WERE. SO THAT
WE CAN DO THESE PROJECTS AND WE
CAN DO THEM TIMELY. AND THE WE
CAN INCREASE THE PACE AND SCALE
WE'RE NOT. SOLVING THE PROBLEM
SO I HOPE THAT TODAY IS NOT
JUST. HEY WE SOLVED IT PAT EACH
OTHER ON THE BACK. IT'S PAST
FIVE HUNDRED THIRTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS OF EARLY ACTION AND
WE'RE DONE. THERE'S A LOT MORE
THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE TO STOP
FIRES. LIKE THE ONES THAT HAVE
DEVASTATED ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES AND WE'VE ALL BEEN
IMPACTED ALL OF US TO GET HAVE
EXPERIENCED. THE DECREASING
CLEAN AIR AS A RESULT OF THESE
FIRES. EVERY PART OF CALIFORNIA
HAS SOME THREAT. FROM WILDFIRE
THIRTY SECONDS. NINETY NINE
MILLION DOLLARS IN THIS BILL IS
SET ASIDE TO STATE OWNED
PROPERTY CONSERVANCY'S. TWELVE
MILLION IS GOING TO THE COASTAL
CONSERVANCY. FOLKS THAT'S MONEY
THAT COULD BE DIRECTED INTO THE
PROJECTS THAT ARE ACTUALLY
REDUCING FUEL IN THE STATE AND
HELPING PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES
AND KEEPING OUR AIR CLEAN AND
REDUCING CARBON EMISSIONS IN
THE STATE WE NEED TO GET OUR
PRIORITIES STRAIGHT. I'M VOTING
FOR THIS TODAY BUT THIS SHOULD
NOT BE THE END. WE SHOULD BE
DOING A WHOLE LOT MORE MORE
RESOURCES REMOVING MORE
BARRIERS. TO GETTING THESE
PROJECTS DONE AND I HOPE YOU
WILL JOIN ME IN THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RISK GALLAGHER MISTER
C. R. TELL YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER. SORRY
I'M NOT GOING TO REITERATE A
LOT OF THE POINTS THAT HAVE
BEEN MADE- I AM GOING TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND I'M GOING
TO SUPPORT IT. BECAUSE IT'S
BETTER THAN NOTHING. AND THAT'S
SAD FOR ME BECAUSE I DON'T
USUALLY SUPPORT THINGS THAT ARE
BETTER THAN NOTHING WHAT I
SUPPORTER THINGS AT WORK.
THINGS THAT ACTUALLY ARE GOING
TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE AND MAKE A
DIFFERENCE QUICKLY. AND THOSE
EFFORTS NEED TO COME FROM. A BI
PARTISAN EFFORT. AND WHAT I
HAVE SEEN IN THIS BILL BUT A
LOT OF MONEY THAT'S SPENT ON
THINGS THAT ARE NOT PART OF
WILDFIRE SUPPRESSION THIS ISSUE
HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR YEARS AND
YEARS AND FOR FROM ONE OF THOSE
PERSONS WHO HAS ACTUALLY BEEN
IN THOSE FIRES AS OPPOSED TO
WATCHING THEM ON TV. I CAN TELL
YOU THAT THE SITUATION IS NOT
GOING TO GET BETTER BY SPENDING
THIS MONEY ON IT AND IT'S NOT
GOING TO BE SOLVED ON APRIL
TWELFTH TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE
IN THE LEGISLATURE WE NEED TO
KEEP WORKING ON THIS I WILL BE
MORE THAN HAPPY TO WORK WITH
PEOPLE ON LEGISLATION THAT
MAKES SENSE IT WILL ACTUALLY
REMOVE THE BARRIERS THAT WE
HAVE THAT ARE PREVENTING US
FROM DOING WHAT WE NEED TO DO
TO PROTECT. OUR COMMUNITIES AND
OUR HOMES AND OUR PEOPLE'S
LIVES. SO I WILL VOTE FOR THIS
TODAY. BUT I JUST WANT PEOPLE
TO KNOW THAT THIS IS NOT THE
ANSWER WE CAN DO BETTER THAN
THIS THANK YOU. SEEING NO OTHER
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION ON
THE ITEM. MR TANG IN A CLOSE.
THANK YOU COLLEGE APPRECIATE
ALL THE- ABBAS DIALOGUE AND
DEBATE OBVIOUSLY WE KNOW THAT
THIS IS NOT ENOUGH WE DO KNOW
THAT WE HAVE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN FUEL REDUCTION
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT THAT WE
NEED TO BE DOING. HI THIS IS
FROM YEARS AND YEARS OF REALLY
DEFERRED ACTION FROM A LACK OF
INVESTMENT YOU KNOW THAT THIS
IS JUST WHAT A DOWN PAYMENT ON
MUCH OF THAT ACTION AND WE THAT
WE DO NEED TO DO THIS NOW SO
APPRECIATE ALL THE SUPPORT IN
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE ON
SB EIGHTY FIVE. THANK YOU.
TECHNISCH TANG AND WITH THAT
CLERK WILL OVER THE ROLE.
MEMBERS DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTED INSIDE OF A. ALL
MEMBERS HEADED TO SARAJEVO.
ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF A.
THE
CLERK WELL. CLOTHES ARE ALL
TIED UP. I SEVENTY TWO DOES
ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES
WITHOUT OBJECTION IMMEDIATE
TRANSMETAL TO THE SENATE.
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE THIS
IS SENATE BILL. EIGHTY SIX. THE
CORPORATION SENATE BILL EIGHTY
SIX BY THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC SOCIAL
SERVICES MAKING APPROPRIATION
AIRFORCE TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BE RELATED TO THE
BUDGET. MISTER KING YOU MAY GET
OPEN I THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
SB EIGHTY SIX MAKES TECHNICAL
CHANGES TO THE GOLDEN STATE
GRANT PROGRAM WE PASSED LAST
MONTH. THE GRANT PROGRAM
PROVIDES A SIX HUNDRED DOLLAR
CHECK FOR EVERY RECIPIENT OF
FSIS IS P. AND THE CAPITAL
PROGRAM IN CALIFORNIA THE
TECHNICAL CHANGES AT THIS BILL
WILL FACILITATE THE ISSUANCE OF
THIS PAYMENT TO THIS VULNERABLE
POPULATION WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. AND MR
FONG YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. I THANK
YOU MR SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHTY SIX
MANY CALIFORNIANS ARE STILL
LEFT VULNERABLE AND STRUGGLING
AS A RESULT OF THE PANDEMIC AND
THIS BILL EXPANDS ANOTHER
HELPING HANDS THE WORKING POOR
AND FOSTER YOUTH THAT LOOK TO
US TO LEAD OUR STATE AND THE
CHALLENGES OF THIS PAST YEAR.
THE GOLDEN STATE SIMILAR SHOULD
REACH ALL ELIGIBLE CALIFORNIANS
SO THAT WE CAN REINVIGORATE OUR
ECONOMY CURB THE RISING TIDE OF
HOMELESSNESS AND MAKE SURE THAT
OUR CONSTITUENTS CAN PROVIDE
FOR THEIR FAMILIES WE HAVE A
DUTY TO PROTECT THOSE
VULNERABLE IN OUR COMMUNITIES
AND FORTUNATELY THAT BECAUSE OF
CONSTITUENTS HAS GROWN
CONSIDERABLY DURING THE
PANDEMIC SB EIGHTY SIX WITH
THOSE THAT DUTY I AM PLEASED TO
SUPPORT TODAY I REGION I'D VOTE
ON SB EIGHTY SIX. THANK YOU
MISS FONG. SEEING THOUGH
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON THE
ITEM MISTER KING YOU MAY CLOSE
IF YOU WISH. WITH THAT CARPOOL
OVER THE ROLE ALL MEMBERS. WHAT
IS THAT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS ABOUT
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF
OUR- IT IS OUT OF.
THE CLERK
WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I
SEVENTY THREE NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES. AND WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE. SB NINETY
THREE. CORKERY SENATE BILL
NINETY THREE BY THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AN ACT RELATING TO
EMPLOYMENT MAKING APPROPRIATION
OR FORCE TAKE AFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BE RELATED TO THE
BUDGET. MISTER TECH. YOU MISTER
CHAIR SB NINETY THREE IS A BILL
TO REALLY AID. WORKERS WHO WERE
SOME OF THE HARDEST HIT IN THE
TIRE STATE. HOSPITALITY WORKERS
WERE LAID OFF AS HOTELS ACROSS
THE CLOSING FRANKLY HAVEN'T
MANY HAVEN'T EVEN. WE OPENED UP
DURING THIS VERY VERY
CHALLENGING YEAR. TO PROVIDE
THESE VULNERABLE WORKERS THE
RIGHT TO RETURN TO WORK IF THEY
WERE LAID OFF DURING THE
PANDEMIC. THE BILL BUILT ON.
THE LEGISLATURE FROM OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN JOSE AB
THIRTY TWO SIXTEEN. BUT WAS
AMENDED TO PROVIDE AGREEMENT
UNFORTUNATELY THAT THAT BILL
WASN'T SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR
LAST YEAR. BUT THERE WAS SIX
MILLION DOLLARS THAT WAS PUT
INTO THE BUDGET FOR ENFORCEMENT
OF LABOR ACTIONS. OF DUTERTE.
INDUSTRIES ARE MOST IMPACTED BY
COPING. SO WELL THERE WAS MONEY
IN THE BUDGET UNFORTUNATELY
THERE WAS A POLICY THAT WAS
EITHER IN THE BUDGET OR PASSED
BY THIS LEGISLATURE WERE SIGNED
BY THE GOVERNOR. THAT ALLOWED
US TO FURTHER CLARIFY
SPECIFICALLY HOW WE SHOULD
ASSIST. HOSPITALITY WORKERS OF
THIS BILL HAS A NUMBER OF
PROVISIONS THAT ARE DIFFERENT
FROM AB THIRTY TWO SIXTEEN OF
PROVIDES NO PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION. IT LIMITS THE RE HIRING
RIGHTS TO EMPLOYEES IMPACTED BY
COVERT NINETEEN. IT CONTAINS A
SUNSET PROVISION FOR TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR. SO AGAIN OF THE
ENFORCEABLE WILL BE DONE BY THE
LABOR AGENCY VERSUS A PRIVATE
RIGHT OF ACTION SO. THOSE
CHANGES WERE MADE FROM EVEN A
PIECE OF LEGISLATION THAT
PASSED THIS BODY PASSED BOTH
BODIES GOT TO THE GOVERNOR'S
DESK. THE WE COULD ABLE TO
REACH AGREEMENT WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. THIS BILL
ALSO INCLUDES SIX MILLION
DOLLARS OF ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
SO THAT WE CAN INSURE THAT
THERE'S PROPER ENFORCEMENT OF
THIS LEGISLATION WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR AYE VOTE
FOR SB NINETY THREE. THANK YOU
MICHELLE MR FONG. A YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. MEMBERS I RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB NINETY THREE
WE ALL KNOW OUR SMALL BUSINESS
ARE SUFFERING RIGHT NOW
ESPECIALLY THOSE AND OUR
HOSPITALITY SPACE BUT WITH MORE
MANDATES AND REQUIREMENTS I
RECOVERY WILL SLOW. INSPIRING
STORIES OF BUSINESS OWNERS
FIGHTING AGAINST ALL ODDS DOING
EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO KEEP
EMPLOYEES HIRED HAVE
UNDOUBTEDLY REACH ALL OF US GET
INSTEAD OF THE INSPIRATION
THEY'VE OFFERED US THIS
LEGISLATURE NOW WANTS TO FORCE
EMPLOYERS TO OVERRIDE THE VERY
PRACTICES THEY'VE USED TO KEEP
THEIR DOORS OPEN. WE SHOULD
NOT. BE IMPOSING NEW
REQUIREMENTS OF BUSINESSES OR
EXPOSING THEM TO EVEN MORE
LIABILITY WHICH- OBSTRUCTED
EVERY HIRING AND RECOVERY. THIS
BILL WORKS AGAINST MOMENTUM
SMALL BUSINESSES NEED TO HELP
THEM HIGHER TO GET PEOPLE OFF
ON OF WOMEN AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE I URGE A NO VOTE ON SB
NINETY THREE. THANK YOU MEMBERS
THIS RUBIO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY WITH
CONCERNS ABOUT SB NINETY THREE
A POLICY BILL WHICH IS BEING
HEARD TODAY AS AN URGENT
TRAILER BILL FIRST ON THE
MERITS OF THE POLICY IT IS
CLEAR THAT THE BILL IS BEING
PRETTY MUCH CERTAIN PREMATURELY
RUSHED. OUT ONE OF THE
ATTEMPTED JUSTIFICATION FOR
THIS POLICY BEING INVITED
TRAILER IS THAT WE SPENT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS IN A BUDGET
TRAILER BILL LAST YEAR AND SB
NINETY THREE IMPLEMENTS THE
POLICY ATTACHED TO THE PREVIOUS
BUDGET ACTION I WAS IN-COMMITTEE EARLIER TODAY AND
ASKED SEVERAL QUESTIONS AND
THOSE QUESTIONS WERE NOT
ANSWERED BY THE BUDGET. STAFF
WHICH AGAIN WORRIES ME ABOUT BY
THE POLICY ASPECT OF THIS BILL.
HOWEVER AND I'M SORRY DURING
THIS HEARING THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WAS UNABLE TO ANSWER
WHAT HAPPENED TO THE ORIGINAL
SIX MILLION DOLLARS FROM LAST
YEAR AFTER I REPEATEDLY ASKED.
I WAS GIVEN DIFFERENT VERSIONS
OF IT. I HAD ALREADY SPOKEN TO
THE- MR TING ABOUT THIS AND
WANTED TO JUST REITERATE THAT
IF WE'RE GOING TO BE SPENDING
TIME IN THE BUDGET HEARING. AND
BAD THE BUDGET- THE BUDGET
STAFF NEEDS TO BE PREPARED TO
ANSWER ALL QUESTIONS ESPECIALLY
IF WE ARE ONLY GIVEN AN HOUR TO
STAND HERE BEFORE. THE BILL IS
PRESENTED TO US TO BE VOTED
UPON. EARLIER IT WAS BROUGHT TO
MY ATTENTION THAT THE SIX
MILLION DOLLARS FROM OUR LAST
YEAR HAVE ALREADY BEEN SPENT
BUT- AGAIN COULD NOT BAD. STOP
COULD NOT ANSWER WHAT HAPPENED
TO THOSE SIX MILLION DOLLARS.
WE HAVE A POLICY COULD MERIT
COMMITTEE PROCESS FOR THIS
REASON AND THE REASON IS THAT
ISSUES AND POLICY CAN BE WORKED
OUT WITH INPUT FROM THE
COMMITTEE CHAIRS AND THE
PUBLIC. THIS MEASURE TODAY IN
FRONT OF US IN MY OPINION IT'S
GOING UP WITHOUT PROPER
OVERSIGHT I CAN'T ANSWER TO MY
CONSTITUENTS AS TO WHY I AM
GOING TO BE VOTING FOR A BILL.
THAT THEY CANNOT DISCUSS WITH
ME. WHEN FOR THE FOLKS IN
CHARGE OF WRITING LEGISLATION
CAN'T ANSWER THE BASIC
QUESTIONS AND COMMITTEE MAKES
ME WONDER HOW THIS IS READY TO
BE SENT TO THE GOVERNOR AND
FIND TODAY. I'M NOT SAYING THAT
IT IS NOT APPROPRIATE TO BRING
THIS BILL UP I'M JUST SAYING
THAT WE NEED MORE TIME TO
PROPERLY VET THIS BILL. YOU THE
RESULTS WILL PROBABLY BE THE
SAME BUT I SEE NO REASON FOR IT
TO BE UP TODAY AS OPPOSED TO
THURSDAY WHEN WE HAVE ANOTHER.
OB FLOOR SESSION. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK BUT
AGAIN I WOULD. ASK RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT WHEN BUDGET.
ISSUES COME UP THE PLEASE DO
NOT GIVE US MORE THAN TWO HOURS
TO DISCUSS THE BILL. AND THEN
EXPECT US TO STAND IN FRONT OF
YOU AND VOTE ON THESE BILLS
THANK YOU. THANK OF ISRAEL
MISTER FLORES. ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO U. S.
B. NINETY THREE A FOR A NUMBER
OF REASONS- I STAND HERE. QUITE
FRANKLY WITH LITTLE BIT OF DEJA
VU. WE SAW THIRTY TWO SIXTEEN
AND LABOR COMMITTEE LAST YEAR.
THEY BARELY GOT OUT WITH ALL
THIRTY TWO SIXTEEN ON THIS
FLOOR LAST YEAR. AND I GOT OUT
WITH FORTY SIX VOTES WENT OVER
TO THE SENATE CAME BACK. THEY
GOT OUT WITH FORTY FOUR VOTES.
THERE IS A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
OPPOSITION. TO THIS PARTICULAR
PIECE OF LEGISLATION. THE
BUDGET CHAIR IN HIS COMMENTS AT
THE BEGINNING. MENTIONED THAT
THIS WAS A POLICY. THERE WAS
MONEY IN THE BUDGET BUT THE
POLICY WASN'T THERE ADMITTING.
THIS IS A POLICY BILL. WE HAVE
NOT RAN THIS BILL THROUGH
POLICY THIS YEAR. THIS BILL HAS
AN EMERGENCY CLAUSE ON IT'LL GO
AFFECTED ME DEEPLY. BUT BECAUSE
WE'RE USING THE BUDGET PROCESS.
WE DON'T HAVE TO DO THAT WE GET
THAT WITH A SIMPLE MAJORITY.
FRIENDS THIS IS INCREDIBLY
PROBLEMATIC. EMPLOYEES HAVE THE
RIGHT TO GET REHIRED AND MOST
EMPLOYERS. WILL ABSOLUTELY CALL
THEM FIRST BECAUSE THEY'RE
TRAINED. IT'S IN THEIR BENEFIT
TO HIRE PEOPLE THAT OF THEY'VE
ALREADY EMPLOYED BUT TO PUT THE
BURDEN. TO PUT THE FEES. THE
FINES THE LIABILITY ON THE
EMPLOYEE ON EMPLOYERS RATHER.
IT'S UNACCEPTABLE SO YOU HAVE
AN EMPLOYEE. THAT DOESN'T
RESPOND TO YOU FOR A COUPLE
WEEKS. AND THEN ALL OF A
SUDDEN- LET'S JUST SAY TEN DAYS
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S TWO WEEKS
OF THE OF THE OPPORTUNITY
RESPOND. YOU'RE GOING TO BE ON
THE HOOK FOR FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS A DAY. IN FEES TO THAT
EMPLOYEE PLUS WHATEVER
LITIGATION COMES AFTER THAT.
THE AMOUNT OF BURDEN. ON THE
BUSINESS TO ME THAT THIS WILL
IMPOSE. IS TREMENDOUS.
COLLEAGUES I WILL JUST SAY THIS
ONE MORE TIME. THE GOVERNOR
VETOED. THIRTY TWO SIXTEEN LAST
YEAR FOR A LOT OF THESE ISSUES
AND I KNOW POPULOUS TAKEN OUT
OF IT BUT IT'S STILL BE
ENFORCEMENT FOR LABOR. STILL
HASN'T ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM IN
THIS BILL. THIS IS NOT A BUDGET
BILL. THIS IS A POLICY BILL
THAT SHOULD HAVE GONE THROUGH
POLICY COMMITTEE UNDER ANY
CIRCUMSTANCES BUT HERE WE ARE
TODAY- IN BUDGET I STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE US TO. JUST NOT OVER
THIS BILL RUN IT THROUGH POLICY
AND HAVE THE ACTUAL DISCUSSIONS
THE NEED TO BE HAD BECAUSE
THERE ARE SO MANY THINGS THAT
NEED TO BE DISCUSSED OCT TO
MAKE THIS BILL UNWORKABLE AND
IN BUDGET THISIS NOT THE TIME.
OR THE PLACE AND QUITE FRANKLY.
IT'S A LITTLE BIT OF USE OF THE
INSTITUTION. THIS RIGHT HERE IS
A BAD PRECEDENT TO SET. WHEN
YOU GET A POLICY THAT IS VETOED
BY THE GOVERNOR YOU MAKE SUBTLE
CHANGES AND RUN IT AS A BUDGET
PLAY. WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT
THE QUALITIES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK REMOVAL. THERE IS FOR
MISTER KALRA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER OF AN HOUR I WANT TO
THANK- A COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
DIEGO AS WELL AS OUR BUDGET
SHARE IN OUR SPEAKER- FOR
WORKING WITH- SENATE COLLEAGUES
AS WELL AS THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE IN RESOLVING THE ISSUES
ARE OUTSTANDING. AT THE END OF
THE SESSION LAST YEAR AS WE
WERE JUST REMINDED OF THIS
POLICY IS ALREADY BEEN VOTED
AND SUPPORTED BY A MAJORITY
SEVERAL TIMES ON THIS FLOOR AND
BY THIS BODY. AS OF THIS IS NOT
A POLICY THAT THAT THAT THAT-
THAT OUR BODY IS NOT SUPPORTING
FACTORS SHOWN OVERWHELMING
SUPPORT TIME AND AGAIN THE
ISSUE WAS AS MENTIONED- THE
GOVERNOR'S VETO. AND SOLVE THIS
RESOLVES THE ISSUES- OF THE
ENVIRONMENT- THROUGH
COLLABORATIVE SPIRIT. THERE'S
BEEN AN UNDERSTANDING OF HOW WE
CAN MOVE FORWARD. AND I WOULD
SAY THAT. THIS IS ACTUALLY A
MORE NARROW VERSION OF WHAT
THIS BODY HAS ALREADY VOTED FOR
SEVERAL TIMES SO THE POLICY AND
THE SUPPORT OF THAT THIS BODY
SUPPORT OF THE POLICY. IS NOT
AND HAS NOT BEEN IN QUESTION I
WAS SAID NOT ONLY IS JUST NOT
RUSHED. BUT JUSTICE IS JUSTICE
FOR THESE WORKERS HAS BEEN
DELAYED FOR WELL OVER SIX
MONTHS. AND SO IT'S THESE
WORKERS THAT ARE THE ONES THAT
HAVE BEEN SUFFERING AND
STRUGGLING AND USE THESE
WORKERS THAT ARE JUST BEING
GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY TO GO
BACK TO THE JOBS THEY ALREADY
HAVE. THESE EMPLOYERS ALREADY
EMPLOYED THEM PUT THEM IN THESE
POSITIONS. SO THIS IS NOT US
TELLING THEM TO HIRE FOLKS THEY
DON'T LIKE OR DON'T WANT. WE'RE
JUST ASKING OPPORTUNITY FOR
THESE WORKERS TO BE ABLE TO GO
BACK TO THEIR PLACE OF
EMPLOYMENT. OUR AND WE HAVE A
RESOLUTION NOW. THAT NOT ONLY.
SUPPORTS THE POLICY AGAIN THAT
THIS BODY HAS SUPPORTED TIME
AND AGAIN BUT ALSO HAS A
RESOLUTION WITH THE GOVERNOR
AND TO RESOLVE THE ISSUES
REGARDING THE VETO. THANK YOU.
THANKS CALMEST GALLAGHER YES I
WOULD JUST ADD WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN JOSE'S SAYS
THIS IS SUCH AN IMPORTANT
POLICY THEN YOU CAN GO THROUGH
THE POLICY COMMITTEES AS IT DID
LAST TIME INSTEAD OF BEING FAST
TRACKED WITH ABUNDANT TIME TWO
HOURS. TO REVIEW THE LANGUAGE
AND THEN BE ABLE TO COME IN AND
VOTE ON THIS THAT'S CLEARLY
NOT. HOW WE SHOULD DO BUSINESS
IN THIS HOUSE BUT THE OTHER
THING I WOULD ADD THAT HASN'T
BEEN SAID IN THIS DEBATE. IS
THE GROSS INCONSISTENCY. THERE
WERE FAST TRACKING THIS POLICY
WELL THE BIGGEST THING FACING
BUSINESSES EVERY BUSINESS IN
THE STATE. IS PPP TAX
CONFORMITY AND WE HAVE THE U.
S. TREASURY COME OUT LAST WEEK
SAYING THAT YES YOU CAN MOVE
FORWARD. THIS WILL NOT AFFECT.
YOUR STIMULUS MONEY AND YET
THAT WHERE'S THAT BILL. WHERE'S
THAT BILL GETTING PUSH FOR THE
BIGGEST THING AFFECTED AND
WANTED PPP DO BY THE WAY. IT
HELP THOSE EMPLOYERS PAY THEIR
EMPLOYEES DURING COVED AND KEEP
IMPORTANT KEEP EMPLOYEES ON.
BUT THERE'S NO URGENCY ON THIS
BODY TO BRING THAT BILL TO THIS
FLOOR AND INSTEAD WERE FAST
TRACKING THIS POLICY. OUR
PRIORITIES ARE OFF I THINK I
MEAN LOOK WE NEED TO BE DOING
THE RIGHT THNGS WE NEED TO BE
FOLLOWING THE RIGHT PART
PROCESS. AND WE NEED TO DO
RIGHT BY ALL PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA THIS IS NOT THE
RIGHT WAY TO DO IT. MS GONZALEZ
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I TRY TO WRITE
DOWN SOME OF THE THINGS WERE
SAID BECAUSE I WANT PEOPLE TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT IS ACTUALLY
HAPPENING THE TIMELINE OF HOW
WE GOT HERE I THINK THAT THAT'S
REALLY QUITE IMPORTANT. NUMBER
ONE YES THIS WAS PASSED OFF A
TOUGHER MORE CONSTRICTED
VERSION WAS PASSED OFF WITH
THIS FLOOR TWICE IN OFF THE
SENATE FLOOR LAST YEAR. THE
GOVERNOR VETOED THAT LANGUAGE
AND SAID THESE ARE THE CHANGES
THAT NEED TO HAPPEN WE
IMMEDIATELY WENT TO MAKING
THOSE CHANGES THOSE WERE THE
CHANGES THAT WERE ASKED FOR BY
THE INDUSTRY AT THE TIME OF
COURSE THEY COME BACK THEY HAVE
NEW REQUEST BUT THAT'S WHAT
WHAT WE DID. THIS IS FAST
TRACKED. BECAUSE OPENING IS
FAST TRACKED AS SOON AS THE
GOVERNOR SAID DISNEYLAND CAN
OPEN IT DO YOU KNOW HOW MANY
HOTELS AROUND DISNEYLAND DO YOU
KNOW HOW MANY OTHER THINGS WILL
BE OPEN BECAUSE DISNEYLAND IS
OPEN THERE IS A NEED TO ENSURE
AS WE OPEN UP THAT WORKERS ARE
MADE WHOLE IN WHO ARE WE
TALKING ABOUT HERE I WANT TO BE
VERY CLEAR. THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE BEEN. AT THE HEIGHT. OF A
FEELING THE EFFECTS OF THIS
PANDEMIC NOT JUST LATINOS BUT
IN PARTICULAR LATINAS WE WENT
INTO THIS PANDEMIC WITH LATINOS
MAKING. FORTY FOUR CENTS ON THE
DOLLAR THE WHITE MALE
COUNTERPART. AND WE'RE ALREADY
DEALING WITH THAT REALITY. THEN
WE ENDED UP HAVING LATINAS LOSE
THEIR JOBS AT A RATE
ASTRONOMICAL COMPARED TO ANY
OTHER GROUP IN WHY IS THAT WHO
ARE WE TALKING ABOUT HERE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT LATINO SERVICE
WORKERS. OLDER MEDINA SERVICE
WORKERS I AM SO TIRED OF PEOPLE
STANDING UP IT'S SEEN THEY THEY
SUPPORT THE LATINO COMMUNITY
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO AT
ADDRESSING A SPECIFIC NEED FOR
OUR COMMUNITY LOOKING THE OTHER
WAY AND SEEN WHAT ABOUT THE
EMPLOYERS WHAT ABOUT THE SMALL
BUSINESSES WELL. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THERE ARE NO SMALL
BUSINESSES IN HERE IT ONLY
APPLIES TO HOTELS WITH OVER
FIFTY ROOMS EVENT CENTERS WITH
OVER A THOUSAND SEATS IN
AIRPORTS THESE ARE NOT YOUR MOM
AND POP BUSINESSES THESE ARE
COMPANIES THAT ACTUALLY CAN DO
THIS AND HAVE BEEN DOING IT IF
THEY'RE UNDER UNION CONTRACT.
THIS IS FOR NON UNION WORKERS
WHO DON'T HAVE THE PROTECTIONS
THAT ARE UNION WORKERS ENJOY
WITH A UNION CONTRACT AND
THAT'S ENSURING THAT WOMEN ARE
BROUGHT BACK TO CLEAN YOUR
HOTEL ROOM. IF THEY'VE BEEN
THERE A LONG IF THEY PUT THE
MOST INTO THE COMPANY THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO BE OFFERED
THEIR JOB NOT FOR TWO WEEKS
LIKE WAS SAID THEY GET FIVE
DAYS TO RESPOND WHY FIVE DAYS A
LOT OF **** EXCUSE MY LANGUAGE
A LOT OF STUFF HAS HAPPENED
DURING THIS PANDEMIC. PEOPLE
HAVE LOST THEIR HOMES PEOPLE
HAVE MOVED PEOPLE HAD TO MOVE
IN WITH EACH OTHER AND GETTING
THE ACTUAL NOTICE MAY TAKE A
LITTLE BIT LONGER THAN NORMAL
FIVE DAYS IS NOT UNREASONABLE
THERE CITIES WHO ARE DOING THAT
NOW. BUT SIX MILLION DOLLARS
THE LATINO CAUCUS FOUGHT HARD
TO GET SIX MILLION DOLLARS TO
DR LAST YEAR DURING THE BUDGET
PROCESS THAT WAS FOR THIS BILL
AND SOME OTHER A LABOR
PROTECTIONS AND THEN THE
GOVERNOR VETOED THIS BILL. WE
WENT BACK WE FIX WHAT THE
INDUSTRY IN THE GOVERNOR HAD
COMPLAINED ABOUT BUT GUESS WHAT
NO PAGA. NO PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION IT'S INCREDIBLE TO
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW IF THE
POSITION NOW. OF OUR COLLEAGUES
ON THE OTHER SIDE IS THAT WE
SHOULD HAVE NO ENFORCEMENT OF
LABOR LAWS IF WE DON'T GIVE SIX
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER TO ENFORCE. THOSE
WHAT ARE WE DOING WE'RE HAVING.
EMIGRE HOW. GO IN AND MAKE A
DEMAND THAT BE SO. BY BY A
LEGAL CASE BY. THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER I MEAN I DON'T
UNDERSTAND HOW WE ENFORCE LABOR
LAWS IF WE DON'T DO ONE OF
THESE THINGS. I'VE HEARD THE
CHAMBER SAY FOR YEARS. NO
PROGRESS NO PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION JUST FUND THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER WELL THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE DOING HERE. WE'RE GIVING
THEM THE ABILITY TO MAKE.
DECISIONS ABOUT WHETHER THIS
WAS VIOLATED I DON'T KNOW HOW
ELSE WE ENFORCE IT WE'RE GONNA
WRITE TICKETS I DON'T KNOW YOU
WANT TO BE IN THE PUBLIC SAFETY
CODE I DON'T THINK ANYONE WANTS
THAT. SO JUST TO BE SURE. WHAT
WE ARE DOING IS NECESSARY
TODAY. YES THAT MONEY WAS IN
YES WE WERE HOPEFUL FOR THE
POLICY THAT ALREADY PASSED
THROUGH THIS CHAMBER LAST YEAR.
WE HAVE NARROWLY TAILORED IT WE
DID THE HARD WORK. THERE ARE
COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE. WHO ARE
OVERLY DEPENDENT ON THE SERVICE
SECTOR THAT ARE SUFFERING. THEY
DON'T KNOW IF AS WE RE OPEN
THEY'RE GOING TO GET HER JOB
BACK. THEY DON'T KNOW THIS WILL
TELL THEM YES BY SENIORITY YOU
WILL. HOLD TIGHT. KEEP YOUR
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE. JUST
WAIT FOR THAT NOTICE THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE
I'M IN THE BUSINESS OF TRYING
TO FIX THINGS FOR MY
CONSTITUENTS. I HOPE ALL OF YOU
ARE TOO AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NIGHT BUT- THANK YOU MISS
GONZALEZ. MISTER BENNETT YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR OF%
THE CHAMBER THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER. I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL- AND I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO POINT ONE
THING OUT AND THAT IS IF YOU
LOOK AT THE BIG PICTURE AND
THAT THERE ARE A LOT OF
SPECIFICS ABOUT THIS BILL AND
HOW NARROWLY FOCUS IT IS
ACCEPTABLE IF YOU LOOK AT THE
BIG PICTURE. WHEN CO WOULD HIT.
WE TURN TO. THE HOSPITALITY
INDUSTRY MORE THAN ANY PLACE
ELSE AND SAID YOU HAVE TO TAKE
THE PAIN. AND TREMENDOUS PAIN
WAS INFLICTED UPON OF THE
WORKERS AND THE BUSINESSES IN
THE HOSPITALITY INDUSTRY AND IF
WE ASKED A SOCIETY RESET MOST
OF THE PAIN OUR CERTAINLY A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF PAIN IS
GOING TO BE- INFLICTED ON THIS
INDUSTRY AND THE WORKERS IN
THAT INDUSTRY OF THE ONES THAT
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE WE TRY TO
DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO GET
THEM BACK WHOLE SINCE WE ASK
THEM TO SACRIFICE FOR COVERT I
KNOW THERE ARE MANY OTHER
DETAILS BUT I KNOW THAT THAT'S
AT LEAST ONE POINT. I THINK WE
SHOULD EMPHASIZE AND THAT IS OF
THE WORKERS THAT WE ASKED TO
SACRIFICE THE MOST OF THE
WORKERS THAT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE TRIED TO MAKE A
GOOD FAITH EFFORT TO MICHAEL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK WITH
BETTER MISTER MURATSUCHI. YOUR
RECOGNITION THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I JUST WANT TO. REYES MY
STANDING CONCERNED THAT- YOU
KNOW WHILE I SUPPORT WORKERS
WHILE I SUPPORT THE POLICY I
VOTED FOR THE BILL LAST YEAR
YOU KNOW I CONTINUE TO HAVE
CONCERNS WHEN WE BLUR THE LINES
BETWEEN YOU KNOW THE POLICY
PROCESS VERSUS THE BUDGET
PROCESS. I WANT TO RAISE MY
STANDING OBJECTION TO THE ABUSE
OF THE BUDGET PROCESS AND
RAISING POLICY ISSUES THROUGH
THE BUDGET PROCESS. THANK YOU
MISTERMURATSUCHI SAYING NO
OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM. MISTER
KING YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. SO LET'S LET'S
GO THROUGH THIS AGAIN. THIS WAS
LEGISLATION THAT WAS
INTRODUCED. TO HELP OF GROUP OF
PEOPLE WHO WERE DESPERATELY IN
NEED OF HELP. PEOPLE WHO
HAVEN'T HAD A PICTURE. FOR
QUITE AWHILE. AND I THINK IF
YOU ASKED ANY OF THEM. AND SAID
HEY DO YOU WANT US TO GO
THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS OR
POLICY PROCESS. BECAUSE WE
CAN'T GET YOUR JOB BACK. LET'S
GUESS WHAT THAT'S THE- YOU
HAVEN'T DONE YOUR JOB. IF YOU
HAVE THE ABILITY. TO HELP US
YOU ASKED US. COULD NOT GO TO
WORK. YOU ASKED US TO STAY HOME.
AND THIS LEGISLATION IS NOT NEW.
WE HAVE A YEAR TO THE BETA WHY
IS IT IMPORTANT BECAUSE THIS IS
ABOUT PEOPLE WHO ARE LAID OFF
BECAUSE OF. THEY NEED HELP
TODAY THEY ACTUALLY NEEDED HELP
LAST YEAR WE SHOULD HAVE GOT
THIS DONE LAST YEAR. BUT
WHATEVER REASON IT DIDN'T AND
THIS IS THE TIME TO MAKE IT
RIGHT. THAT'S WHY IT'S
IMPORTANT BECAUSE WE HAVE A
GROUP OF WORKERS WHO HAVE BEEN
UNEMPLOYED UNEMPLOYMENT
HOPEFULLY ON UNEMPLOYMENT
BECAUSE WE DON'T HELD WELL
THAT'S BEEN GOING. WE DON'T
EVEN HAVE THE MAYBE THEY
HAVEN'T EVEN BEGIN THE TRUCKS.
BUT IF WE CAN HELP AS WE RE
OPEN HELP THEM GET THEIR JOB
BACK WITH THEIR EMPLOYER. IN A
WAY THAT'S REASONABLE IN A WAY
THAT WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
AGAIN. HAVE A GOVERNMENT AGENCY
PROVIDE. A CHECK AGAINST OF THE
MEASURE THAT THIS BILL GETS
IMPLEMENTED. WE ALL KNOW WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN WE DO BILLS WITH
THERE'S NO ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISM WHEN THERE'S NOBODY
WATCHING IT'S SELECTIVELY.
IMPLEMENTED SO AGAIN. THESE ARE
AGAIN LOW WAGE WORKERS THESE
ARE NOT PEOPLE WHO GET PAID A
LOT OF MONEY THESE ARE FOLKS
WHO ARE ABLE TO SOCK AWAY
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS TO HAVE
WHETHER THIS LAST YEAR. AND
AGAIN. I'LL I UNDERSTAND THE
ARGUMENT WE DIDN'T HEAR THAT
ARGUMENT WE DISTILLED DIVISION
PROPOSAL WE DIDN'T HEAR THAT
ARGUMENT WILL WE JUST DID THE
RTC EXPANSION ALL THESE ISSUES
THAT WE HAD TO GO DO BECAUSE-
WE'RE INDEPENDENT. SO AGAIN I
APPRECIATE THE DEBATE I
APPRECIATE THE FEEDBACK THIS
LEGISLATION IS NOT SOMETHING
HIS BODY HASN'T SEEN. THIS IS
NOT NEW SO FOR THE FEW NEW
MEMBERS WHO ARE HERE. AGAIN
LET'S DO SOMETHING FOR THIS
GROUP OF WORKERS WHO'VE BEEN
SUFFERING FOR NOW OVER A YEAR.
AND LET'S HELP THEM TODAY THANK
YOU TECHNISCH CHAIN WITHOUT
THE CLERK WILL OVER THE ROLE
MEMBERS. THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF A RESERVE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS HEADED IS AT ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
ALL MY RICHARD IS OUT OF A.
THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF.
HIGHS FIFTY ONE KNOWS NINETEEN
THAT MEASURE PASSES. PARIS ARE
MOVING TO ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING. FILE ITEMS TWENTY ONE
THREE TWENTY THREE PASS AND
RETAIN. THIS IS FILE ITEM.
TWENTY FOUR. AB FIVE ZERO THREE
BY MR STONE. CORRECT ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE OH THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER STONE AND OTHERS
AN ACT RELATING TO JUVENILES MR
STONE EMAIL BUT THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS SB FIVE OH
THREE IS A STRAIGHTFORWARD AND
RESEARCH BASED. PROPOSAL THAT
WOULD CHANGE HOW WE DEAL WITH
YOU WHO ARE ON PROBATION RIGHT
NOW IT DEPENDS THE WAY TOO MUCH
ON THE ZIP CODE OF YOU AND THE
COLOR FOR YOU. TO DICTATE THE
TERMS THAT THEY'RE GETTING ON
PROBATION IN SOME COUNTIES. YOU
SPEND AN AVERAGE OF SIX MONTHS
ON PROBATION AND OTHERS TWO AND
A HALF YEARS AND THE NUMBER OF
CONDITIONS THAT ARE PUT ON
YOUTH CAN VARY WIDELY BASED ON
THE COUNTY AND BASED ON THE
RACE UPWARDS OF FIFTY.
CONDITIONS THAT IN A WAY ARE
DESIGNED TO ENSURE THAT THAT
YOU CANNOT SUCCEED AND WILL
CONTINUE TO BE IN THE CYCLE OF
BEING PUT BACK ON PROBATION OR
EVEN. INCARCERATED FOR
VIOLATING PROBATION CONDITIONS.
FOR SOME VERY VERY MINOR
OFFENSES THAT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS BILL WITH THE
PROBATION CHIEFS. BECAUSE WE
KNOW THAT THEY'RE THE ONES WHO
ARE GOING TO HAVE TO IMPLEMENT
THIS AND TO MAKE SURE THAT IT
MEETS ALTERNATELY THEIR
STANDARDS AND WHAT IT REALLY
DOES IS TWO THINGS. ONE IS IT
TAYLOR SAID THE PROBATION
CONDITIONS TO THE NEEDS OF THE
YOUTH AND THE CERTAIN THE
PARTICULAR CIRCUMSTANCES. SO
MORE CONDITIONS IF IT'S A MORE
SERIOUS CRIME. LET FEWER
CONDITIONS IF IT'S NOT SUCH A
SERIOUS CRIME AND IT
ESTABLISHES A SIX MONTH
TIMELINE SO THAT A KID NEEDS TO
HAVE THEIR CASE REVIEWED. EVERY
SIX MONTHS SO THEY DON'T JUST
LANGUISH ON PROBATION WITHOUT
ANY OPPORTUNITY TO GET OFF. CAN
THIS IS RESEARCH BASED. THIS IS
TO ADDRESS THE DISPARITIES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA AND ENSURE
THAT WE ARE GETTING KIDS
THROUGH THE PROBATION PROCESS.
ADDRESS THE ISSUES THAT THEY
NEED TO ADDRESS BEFORE THEY
COME BACK INTO OUR SOCIETY COME
BACK IN OUR SOCIETY GO TO
SCHOOL GO TO JOBS. THIS IS FOR.
NONCUSTODIAL WARDS ONLY NAKISKA
YOU AWARDS NOT THOSE ARE WHO
ARE N. THE END JUVENILE HALLS
OR- IN THE STATE'S SYSTEM BUT
NONCUSTODIAL WORDS ONLY AND I
ASK FOR YOUR ITEMS. TAKING DOWN.
SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
I DON'T SORRY I MISSED COOPER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER A QUESTION FOR
THE AUTHOR YOU CAN DEFINE FOR
THE MEMBERSHIP. LEVELS FROM
CLEAR ON CUSTODIAL VERSUS NON
CUSTODIAL WARD WELL MEMBERS
DON'T ARE FAMILIAR WITH THAT
TERM. WITHOUT OBJECTION SURE
RIGHT AND I COULD STILL BE WARD
IS ONE THAT IS AS I JUST SAID
IS NOT IN JUVENILE HALL OR NOT
IN THE STATE JUVENILE SYSTEM
THAT THEY ARE IN THE COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
IT. SO A. B. FIVE OH THREE
TREES OFFICE IS THE SAME WITH
THIS ROBBERY RAPE ANY TYPE OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT OR MANSLAUGHTER
THE MOST COURTS CAN DO THE
WHOPPING SIX MONTHS PROBATION
IN THE SIX MORE MONTHS WILL
DETERMINE ADDITIONAL SIX MONTHS
IS WARRANTED THE BILL STATES
THAT THE EXTENSION MUST BE FOR
CLEAR. AND CONVINCING SETTING
UNREASONABLE STANDARD AND NOT
EVEN DEFINING WHAT THAT MEANS
WHERE IN OUR SYSTEM DO WE HAVE
A CLEAR AND CONVINCING STANDARD
NOT THE PENAL CODE NOT ANY
JUSTICE SYSTEM- THIS TOTALLY
DISCOUNTS THE VICTIM'S WELFARE
AND THE WELFARE STATE TO THE
COMMUNITY AT LARGE. IF THE
CONVICTION IS ANY TYPE OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT OR VIOLENT
CRIME. EVEN WITH MULTIPLE
VICTIMS THEIR DISCOUNTED AND
IGNORED THIS BILL. THE BILL
ALSO LIMITS HOW MUCH TIME THE
COURTS CAN GIVE A JUVENILE
UNDER SEVENTEEN NO MATTER THE
CRIME. UNDER THIS BILL A
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD CAN ONLY
RECEIVE THE MIDDLE TERM. OF AN
ADULT FOR THE SAME OFFENSE I'M
GONNA SAY THAT AGAIN FOR MY
pSEVENTEEN YEAR OLD CAN ONLY
RECEIVE THE MIDDLE TERM. OF AN
ADULT FOR THE SAME OFFENSE. FOR
THE SANDARD FOR THE OBVIOUSLY
THE MID OFFENSE BASE OFFENSE IF
YOU KILL SOMEONE YOUR JUVENILE
FOR YEARS. IF YOU ROB SOMEBODY
TWO YEARS RAPE SOMEBODY THREE
YEARS THAT'S THE MID TERM OF
THE BASE. A LOT OF FOLKS IF
YOU'RE IN JUVENILE HALL YOU'RE
IN NOT THE STORY WOULD BE A
GROUP HOME IT'S A LOT OF KIDS
ARE IN GROUP HOMES A LOT OF
MEMBERS HAVE GROUP HOMES THEIR
DISTRICT. FOR SEX OFFENDERS
JUVENILE SEX OFFENDERS WITH
THAT. SO THE THING IS. TODAY
CURRENTLY IN OUR PRISON SYSTEM.
YOU CAN GET INFORMATION BY THE
PROBATION DEPARTMENT BE GIVEN
SIX MONTHS. MAKING EXTENDED SIX
MONTHS WITH THE COURT'S
PERMISSION THAT'S AVAILABLE
TODAY TO US. THE COURT CAN
GRANT INFORMAL PROBATION AND
GRANTS SIX MONTHS AND EXTEND
THEMSELVES. MAY ALSO HAVE
DEFERRED ENTRY OF JUDGMENT.
WHICH IF THE PERSON DOES
EVERYTHING IT IT TERMINATES
AFTER YEAR. BUT THE PROBLEM IS
IF THEY'RE GOING THROUGH THIS
WHAT THEY'RE GOING THROUGH
ANGER REGRESSION. THINKING FOR
A CHANGE. SUBSTANCE ABUSE. SIX
WEALTHY ARE DONE IN SIX. THE
COURT CAN KICK THEM SO. THERE'S
A LOT OF MOVING PARTS THIS WITH
A LOT FOR REFORMS. A LOT FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM. AND
LAW FOR MINORS DJJ IS GOING
AWAY. WE SUPPORT ON THAT BILL A
LITTLE WHILE AGO. AND YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE TWENTY FIVE YEAR
OLDS. IN JUVENILE HALL WALKING
AROUND TWENTY FIVE YEAR OLD
GROWN MAN. YOU HAVE THAT
EVENTUALLY IT WOULD AND THAT'S
HOW IT IS. SO THAT'S WHAT
HAPPENS SO THERE'S A LOT OF
MOVING PARTS TO THIS WELL IT
SOUNDS GOOD AND THE YOU THINK
DJJ SPEAKER PUBLISHER ANALYSIS
IS THREE HUNDRED. WILL BE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY SOON MOSTER
JUVENILE HALLS HAVE BEEN
EMPTIED OUT SO THE KIDS THAT
ARE THERE RIGHT NOW OR SOME OF
YOUR- WORST OF THE WORST KIDS
BAD KIDS IN INDEED THE- THAT IS
A RICH SECOND CHANCE BUT- THIS
JUST SETS A BAD PRECEDENT. WHAT
WE'RE DOING WITH THIS AND IT
WILL EXIT WE HAVE A PROCESS
RIGHT NOW PROVISION APARTMENT
CAN GRANT THIS. THE JUDGE CAN
GRANT IT. CURRENT DAY BUT YOU
KNOW WHAT WE SAYING WITH THIS
WHEN IT'S OKAY. LIKE I SAID.
FOR SIX MONTHS FOR EVERYBODY
DOESN'T DEFINE WHAT IT IS. WELL
I DON'T CARE IF IT'S CRYSTAL
CLEAR NOT TO STILL DEAL. BUT
SIX MONTHS. AND YOU CAN BE
RELEASED POTENTIALLY. AFTER SIX
MONTHS. FOR ROBBERY FOR RAPE
RIGHT NOW A LOT OF JUVENILE
HALLS IN YOUR BOOK TO THE
JUVENILE HALL FOR THE MOST
PART. YOU GET OUT THE REAL
ISSUE AND GIVEN THOSE TO APPEAR
SO SEVERAL COUNTY THEY RELEASED
JUTEL'S FOR RATE. VERY VIOLENT
RAPES. WERE JUNE OF THE BEATING
UP YOUNG GIRLS AND RAPED HIM.
THEY'RE GONNA CITATION COURT TO
APPEAR. ROBBERY ROBINSON- THE
FIREARM BEING SOMEBODY UP
VICIOUSLY THEY WERE GIVEN A
CITATION TO APPEAR FOR COURT.
SO WE'VE DONE A LOT OF REFORMS
BUT- FOLKS IT'S TIME TO SLOW
DOWN. WITH WHAT WE'RE DOING.
AND LIKE I SAID. IT'S THE
NUANCES LAST COST IS A MATTER
IF YOU'RE IN JUVENILE HALL-
GROUP OVER SOMEWHERE ELSE. THE
BOTTOM LINE IS YOU ARRESTED YOU
WERE CHARGED. AND READY TO GO
THROUGH THE SYSTEM ARE YOU BEEN
SLEEPING SINCE ACTUALLY. SO YOU
KNOW WE GOTTA CHANGE THIS AND-
LIKE I SAID WE'VE DONE A LOT
THIS THIS GOES WAY TOO FAR. AND
AT WHAT POINT DO WE STOP ABOUT
THE VICTIMS OR MULTIPLE VICTIMS
ESPECIALLY SEXUAL ASSAULT. THAT
HAPPENS A LOT WITH OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE. AND WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THE SUSPECTS IN THOSE
CASES GET HELP. AND GET THE
REHABILITATION BUT THERE'S NO
MAGIC BUT WE'RE HEY SIX MONTHS
AND YOU'RE FINE YOU'RE A GOOD
PERSON AGAIN. I MEAN HAPPEN
SOME CASES BUT IT TOOK TIME TO
DEVELOP THIS TAPE BEHAVIOR AND
IT TAKES TIME FOR THE RECOVERY
THE BILL. SIX MONTHS YOUR BILL
FOR SIX MORE MONTHS. SO IT'S
JUST I GUESS SAID. IT'S THIS
THIS BILL IS IF IT DOESN'T WORK
RIGHT NOW- WE'RE GONNA PUT THE
VICTIMS FIRST ALWAYS SAID THAT
IN MY SEVEN YEARS HERE. THEY
WERE TALKING. YOUNG VICTIMS A
LOT OF THESE CASES. THERE IS
COVER. MURATSUCHI YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH YOU KNOW AS A-
FORMER CRIMINAL PROSECUTOR. I
CAN TELL YOU. THAT YOU KNOW
WHEN I TALKED ABOUT. THE TERMS
AND CONDITIONS OF PROBATION I
NEVER TALKED ABOUT I YOU KNOW I
NEVER HEARD ANYONE HAVE ANY
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT. YOU KNOW
LET'S LOCK UP MORE BLACK AND
BROWN KIDS FOR A LONGER PERIOD
OF TIME LET'S LET'S CREATE
AVENUES TO KEEP BLACK AND BROWN
KIDS IN CUSTODY OF FOR A LONGER
PERIOD OF TIME WELL WE TALKED
ABOUT. WERE NOT ONLY IN THE
CASE OF A JUVENILE COURT AND I
NEVER PRACTICE IN JUVENILE
COURT AND SO I'M LOOKING TO
MISTER CUNNINGHAM MAYBE YOU CAN
ENLIGHTEN US IN TERMS OF. YOU
KNOW THE INS AND OUTS OF. OF
JUVENILE COURT BUT- YOU KNOW IN
GENERAL I KNOW THAT. THE
FUNDAMENTAL PRINCIPLE OF
CRIMINAL SENTENCING- IS
PROPORTIONALITY THAT WHEN YOU
HAVE MORE SERIOUS CRIMES YOU
GET A LONGER SENTENCE AND THAT
INCLUDES PROBATION NOW I AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT THE BASICS OF
JUVENILE COURT IS THAT THE
FOCUS IS ON REHABILITATION BUT
EVEN WITH REHABILITATION YOU
KNOW SIX MONTHS. HOW CAN YOU
CHANGE A KID'S AND HIS LIFE
AROUND IN A SIX MONTH PERIOD NO
I AGAIN I TALK WITH THE AUTHOR
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE
PROVISIONS FOR THE COURT TO
EXTEND THE PERIOD YOU KNOW IT
IN A WAY THAT IS IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE WARD OF THE
JUVENILE. AWARD BUT THERE ARE
OTHER CONSIDERATIONS THAT GO ON
THE BALANCING ACT IN TERMS OF
SENTENCING LIKE MAKING SURE
THAT VICTIMS IN A HAVE ENOUGH
THAT YOU HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BE TO RECEIVE RESTITUTION
KNOW THAT IF OF THE PART TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S ENOUGH
TIME FOR THE- THE WARD TO
RECEIVE ENOUGH TIME TO COMPLY
WITH THE TERMS AND CONDITIONS
INCLUDING PARTICIPATING. AND
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS. I
THINK SIX MONTHS. YOU KNOW JUST
HAVING A FLAT OUT SIX MONTH CUT
OFF FOR ALL JUVENILE WARD- IS.
IN A PROGRAM THAT'S WHY I WILL
BE OPPOSING THIS BILL. ALL THE
BAIT. HAVING SEIZED. MISTER
CUNNINGHAM YOUR RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I GOT
CALLED OUT BY MY COLLEAGUE FROM
MANHATTAN BEACH SO I GUESS I
GOTTA I GOTTA TALK- LOOK I
REPRESENTED. KIDS IN JUVENILE
COURT- IT'S THE APPROPRIATE
PLACE FOR THEM IF THEY'RE UNDER
EIGHTEEN NOT LEGAL AGE OF
MAJORITY. IT'S A REHABILITATION
FOCUS THAT'S A GOOD THING
THAT'S WHAT WE WANT- BUT IT
OCCURS TO ME THOUGH. THAT ASK
YOU TO THINK ABOUT THIS. IF
YOU'RE SEVENTEEN YEARS OLD
THREE HUNDRED SEVENTEEN YEARS
AND THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
FOUR DAYS OLD. ADESH I'VE
EIGHTEEN. AND YOU RATE A
THIRTEEN YEAR OLD. IT'S PERHAPS
THE CASE THAT SIX MONTHS ISN'T
LONG ENOUGH FOR THE COURT TO
ADDER ADEQUATELY SUPERVISE YOU
AND FIGURE OUT WHETHER YOU HAVE
BEEN REHABILITATED I WOULD
SUBMIT TWELVE MONTHS PROBABLY
ISN'T LONG ENOUGH I'D- SO I
WOULD LIKE THIS BILL TO NOT
PASS. I'D ENCOURAGE YOU TO VOTE
NO LET'S GO BACK TO WORK A
LITTLE BIT AND HAVE SOME
EXEMPTIONS FOR SERIOUS HEINOUS
VIOLENT CRIMES. AND HAVE A BILL
THAT WE CAN ALL BE PROUD THANK
YOU. SEEING NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. ON THIS
ITEM MISTER STONE YOU MAY CLOSE
SURE THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
LET'S LET'S GET SOME OF OUR
FRAME OF REFERENCE HERE CORRECT.
THE SIX MONTHS IS NOT A
LIMITATION IS ESSENTIALLY A
REVIEW. SO CERTAINLY IF THE
OFFENSE IS. BAD ENOUGH AND I
AND I KNOW WE WANT TO SORT OF
LOOK AT THE WORST OF THE WORST
OF THE WORST SITUATION AND
EMOTIONALY. THAT JUST SEEMS TO
BE VERY COMPELLING. BUT A COURT
IS GOING TO HAVE TO REVIEW THAT
CASE AFTER SIX MONTHS AND IF
THEY'RE UNDER THE CURRENT BILL.
IS CLEAR AND CONVINCING
EVIDENCE ALTHOUGH WE ARE
WORKING WITH OUR SPONSORS ARE
STAKEHOLDERS TO LOOK AT
CHANGING THAT STANDARD. TO SORT
OF MEET SOME OF WHAT THE
CONCERNS HAVE BEEN RAISED HERE.
AND THE INITIAL NOTION OF THE
CLEAR AND CONVINCING IS WE'RE
HOLDING KIDS AND YES WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT KIDS WHO ARE
POTENTIALLY. GUILTY OF IT'S A
VERY SERIOUS CRIMES ARE THEY
GOING TO BE NONCUSTODIAL ARE
THEY GOING TO BE. OUT IN THE
COMMUNITY IF IT'S THAT BAD OF A
CRIME YEAH NO PROBABLY NOT.
THESE ARE KIDS HOWEVER WHO
FEDERAL PROBATION FOR TWO.
THREE YEARS BECAUSE THEY'RE
GUILTY OF SHOPLIFTING. BECAUSE
THERE TRUANT THAT'S REALLY WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO CHANGE AND SO
YES A COURT IS GOING TO HAVE TO
REVIEW THAT CASE AFTER SIX
MONTHS. AND IF THERE'S A REASON
BECAUSE THEY'RE IN REHAB.
BECAUSE THEY'RE DOING A
RESTITUTION PROGRAM. BECAUSE
THEY ARE WORKING WITHIN THE
COMMUNITY BASED ON THE TERMS OF
THEIR PROBATION. COULD THAT GET
EXTENDED FOR THESE VERY VERY
SERIOUS CRIMES. ABSOLUTELY
THAT'S HOW THE BILL'S DESIGN.
THAT'S WHY THE CONDITIONS THAT
ARE BEING CREATED IN THIS BILL.
THE PROBATION CONDITIONS HAVE
TO BE WHAT IS SPECIFIC TO THAT
CHILD. INTO THAT CIRCUMSTANCE
SO WE DON'T HAVE THE CASE WHERE
SOMEONE HAS COMMITTED A MINOR
OFFENSE. AND HAS VERY VERY
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF CONDITION
PROBATION CONDITIONS PUT ON
THEIR PROBATION. ALMOST
GUARANTEEING THAT THERE THAT
THEY WILL FAIL. AND NO THERE IS
NOT A DISCUSSION THIS IS A
BLACK OR BROWN KID OR THIS IS A
KID FROM THE ZIP CODE SO
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE MORE.
PROBATION CONDITIONS PUT ON
THEM THE FACTS OF THE MATTER
ARE HOWEVER IF IT IS A BLACK OR
BROWN KID OR FROM CERTAIN ZIP
CODES THEY WILL HAVE. MORE
CONDITIONS PUT ON THEM. THAT'S
A FACT IS THAT BLATANT RACISM.
IS IT SORT OF. A BLATANT
ATTEMPT TO GO AFTER CERTAIN ZIP
CODES MAYBE MAYBE NOT IS IT
INHERENT RACISM ABSOLUTELY.
THAT'S REALLY WHAT'S AT STAKE
IN THAT WITH THIS BILL AND
THAT'S WHY WE'RE TRYING TO TAKE
THE RESEARCH. AND TRYING TO
TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT THESE KIDS
ARE GOING THROUGH HOW THEY'RE
BEST SERVED WITHIN PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS. AND ENSURE THAT
THEY CAN BE. A PROPERLY
SUPERVISED HAVE APPROPRIATE
CONDITIONS PUT ON THEM BASED ON
THE SEVERITY OF THE CRIME.
BASED ON THE CIRCUMSTANCES THAT
THEY FIND THEMSELVES IN. AND
BUILD SOME BETTER CONSISTENCY
ACROSS THE STATE COUNTY TO
COUNTY. SO IF A CHILD IS GUILTY
OF THE WORST OF THE WORST OF
THESE HEINOUS CRIMES AS AS AS
BEEN DETERMINED. THERE ARE
APPROPRIATE MECHANISMS IN PLACE
TO ENSURE THAT THEY ARE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE. AND THAT THEY ARE
GOING TO SERVE. WHATEVER
PUNISHMENT WE FEEL IS
APPROPRIATE. BUT TOO OFTEN
THESE ARE MINOR OFFENSES AND
THESE KIDS ARE TREATED THE SAME
AS IF THEY ARE A VERY SERIOUS
OFFENDERS THAT'S THE PIECE WE
HAVE TO GET OUT FROM UNDERNEATH
HERE AND ENSURE THAT THOSE
TERMS OF PROBATION ARE
APPROPRIATE THAT THEY'RE
ACTUALLY BEING REVIEWED. ON A
SIX MONTH BASIS SO THAT THEY
DON'T JUST LANGUISH FOR TWO OR
THREE YEARS BECAUSE AND THIS IS
WHAT HAPPENS. COURTS HEAD DOOR
DON'T WANT TO SEE HIM AGAIN FOR
ANOTHER YEAR OR FOR TWO YEARS
OR THE PROBATION SYSTEM JUST
ONCE HAS THEM CYCLING ON
PROBATION WITHOUT AN ABILITY TO
GET OFF. AND ADDRESS HAVE BEEN
DRESSED WHATEVER UNDERLYING
ISSUE THERE IS THAT'S WHY THIS
MAKES SENSE IT IS BASED ON THE
RESEARCH IT IS BASED ON HOW WE
ARE RESPONSIBLE TO OUR KIDS.
AND IT IS INTENTIONALLY
DESIGNED THIS WAY TO START TO
UNDO. THE INHERENT RACISM THAT
IS BUILT INTO THE PROBATION
SYSTEM AND HOW WOULD DEALS WITH
KIDS OF COLOR AND KIDS IN OUR
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I'VE-
WITH THAT KERR CALL THE ROLL.
SORRY ABOUT ALL THE VERGE
VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A.
MR STONE MOOSE
CALL. PASS RETAIN A BALANCE
TWENTY FIVE THIS IS FILE ITEM.
TWENTY SIX. HI MR MEDINA
KRIKORIAN. ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
THIRTY SEVEN BY SOME REMEMBER
MEDINA AND OTHERS AN ACT
RELATING THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
MISTER MEDINA. THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. AB THREE
THIRTY SEVEN SEEKS TO AMPLIFY
THE VOICE OF STUDENTS AND
INCREASE THE REPRESENTATION ON
THE BOARD OF GOVERNORS AT THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
THE STUDENT MEMBER OF THE BOARD
OF GOVERNORS EXERCISE A
CRITICAL ROLE IN REPRESENTING
MORE THAN TWO POINT ONE MILLION
STUDENTS AT THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. THERE ARE
CURRENTLY TWO STUDENT MEMBERS
ON THE BOARD OF GOVERNORS BUT
ONLY ONE HAS THE ABILITY TO
VOTE. THE BOARD OF GOVERNORS
PLAYS A SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN
SHAPING THE STUDENT EXPERIENCE
AT CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. YET STUDENTS LACK
ADEQUATE REPRESENTATION. IN
SUCH AN EXPANSIVE AND DIVERSE
HIGHER EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM IT IS
SOMETIMES SIMPLY UNFEASIBLE THE
ONE STUDENT CAN DO JUSTICE TO
REPRESENT THE PLURALITY OF
THOUGHT AND DIVERSITY OF
EXPERIENCE CONTAIN AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM. AB
THREE THIRTY SEVEN WOULD ALLOW
BOTH STUDENT MEMBERS OF THE
BOARD OF GOVERNORS TO BE FULLY
EMPOWERED VOTING MEMBERS AT THE
BEGINNING OF THEIR APPOINTMENT.
AB THREE THIRTY SEVEN WOULD NOT
ALTER ANY PART OF THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS APPOINTMENT PROCESS
OR THE TOTAL NUMBER. OF
MEMBERS. THEREFORE AB THREE
THIRTY SEVEN WOULD ALLOW FOR
MORE RECOGNITION OF THE DIVERSE
RANGE OF STUDENT VIEWS AND SEND
A STRONG MESSAGE ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF INCLUDING THE
STUDENT PERSPECTIVE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MR MEDINA.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM OR CALL THE ROLL. IT
IS OUR VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
SERVICE OUT OF VOTE. THE CLARK
WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I.
SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES PASS RETAIN A
PILOT OF TWENTY SEVEN. IS FILE
ITEM. TWENTY EIGHT. AB. FOUR
NINETEEN. FIVE MS DAVIS
CORPORATE ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
NINETEEN BY SOME REMEMBER
DAVIES AN ACT RELATING TO
CRIMINAL PROCEDURE MISS DAVIS
YOU MAY OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS TODAY I'M HERE
TO PRESENT AB FOUR ONE NINE.
UNDER CURRENT LAW PERSONALLY
IDENTIFYING INFORMATION ABOUT A
VICTIM OR WITNESS SUCH AS
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER
BIRTHDATE EMPLOYER
IDENTIFICATION NUMBER AND
BIOMETRIC INFORMATION AMONGST A
HOST OF OTHER THINGS ARE NOT
PROTECTED. THE DEFENDANT OR
THEIR FAMILY COULD REQUEST AND
RECEIVE THAT INFORMATION
WITHOUT A COURT ORDER. AB FOUR
ONE NINE IT'S A SIMPLE MEASURE
TO PROTECT CERTAIN TYPES OF
PERSONALLY IDENTIFYING
INFORMATION THAT CAN BE
DISCLOSED TO A DEFENDANT. IF
SUCH INFORMATION IS NEEDED BY
THE DEFENSE TO BUILD THE CASE
THIS BILL KEEPS CURRENT LAW
INTACT BY ALLOWING THE COURTS
REQUIRE THAT INFORMATION BE
GIVEN. AB FOUR ONE NINE HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO HELP GIVE VICTIMS
AND WITNESSES OF CRIME. THE
PEACE OF MIND THAT IF THEY COME
FORWARD WITH INFORMATION ABOUT
A CASE THAT STATE CAN PROTECT
THE MOST VULNERABLE INFORMATION
ABOUT THEM. THE BILL PASSED AND
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
UNANIMOUSLY AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK AND I VOTE. A MYSTERIOUS MR
GALLAGHER HERE RECOGNIZE. THE
QUESTION FROM MY COLLEAGUE FROM
THE GONNA GO. WITHOUT OBJECTION
IS THIS YOUR FIRST BILL. IT'S
CERTAINLY. ALL RIGHT WELL THIS
THIS IS A GREAT BILL BY THE WY
I'M GOING TO SUPPORT IT- VERY
IMPORTANT MEASURE- BUT I NOTED
IN YOUR BILL LIKE YOU CHANGE.
SECTION FIVE THIRTY POINT FIVE
FIVE- TO ALLOW FOR THIS YOU
KNOW TO ENSURE THAT'S NOT
DISCLOSE DID YOU CONSIDER ALSO
ADDING IN. SECTION FIVE THIRTY
POINT FIVE SIX. TO THIS BILL
WHICH I THINK WOULD MAKE IT
EVEN STRONGER. YOU MAY ADDRESS
SEVEN DAVIES. I'M SO. THIS CASE
I THINK IT WAS NECESSARY OKAY
WOULD YOU MAYBE DO THAT AS A
FRIENDLY AMENDMENT ON THE FLOOR-
BECAUSE I MEAN I THINK THIS IS
IMPORTANT TO DO THAT- TODAY-
ALL RIGHT THAT THAT'S ENOUGH
PAID. THIS MEASURE FOR TODAY MY
COLLEAGUE- AS I SAID THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT MEASURE WE APPRECIATE
YOUR HARD WORK AND IT'S GOOD TO
SEE YOU GET A BILL TO THE FLOOR
SO FAST- OTHERS I THINK IN THIS
ROOM MAYBE EVEN HAVEN'T EVEN
GOT TO THE FLOOR YET- WE'LL
TALK ABOUT THEM LATER. THANK
YOU THAT IS ENOUGH MISS
GALLAGHER SEEING NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. MISS
DAVIS YOU MAY CLOSE WE WISH.
THANK YOU ARE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. MICHAEL OF THE
ROLE EVERY. IS THAT ABOUT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS AND VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF. A DESIRE TO VOTE.
OR CLERK WILL. WELL CLOSER ALL
TIED OUT I SEVENTY NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES. PASS RETAIN A
FILE ITEM TWENTY NINE THIS IS
FILE ITEM THIRTY AB THIRTEEN
EIGHTEEN BY MR STONE. CORP
QUARRY ASSEMBLY RULE THIRTEEN
EIGHTEEN BY SIN REMEMBER STONE
AN ACCOLADE IN THE CIVIL
ACTIONS. MR STONE YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THIS
BILL IS TO CLOSE A BIT OF A
LOOPHOLE IN JUVENILE COURT
CURRENTLY THE MINERS IN
JUVENILE COURT FOR DEPENDENCY
ACTION IF THEY NEED TO CHANGE
THEIR NAME OR THEIR GENDER CAN
BE DONE IN JUVENILE COURT WITH
THE FILING THERE HOWEVER IN THE
DELINQUENCY SIDE OF JUVENILE.
IT CAN'T BE DONE AND IF THERE
NEEDS TO BE A NAME CHANGE OR A
GENDER CHANGE THEY HAVE TO GO
OUT TO CIVIL COURT WHAT THIS
BILL DOES WOULD ALLOW THAT
PETITION LAW THE ATTORNEY FOR
THE YOUTH IN JUVENILE COURT TO
FILE THAT NAME OR GENDER
CHANGE. IN JUVENILE COURT AND
IT ALSO DOES AWAY WITH THE
OBLIGATION TO NOTIFY OR TO IT
TO PUBLISH THAT NAME CHANGE IN
A- NEWSPAPER OF. OF GENERAL
DISTRIBUTION WHICH IS WHAT
HAPPENS IF THERE'S A NAME
CHANGE OR GENDER CHANGE IN
CIVIL COURT. SO THIS IS A- A
BILL THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT THE
GLBT COMMUNITY. WHO ARE.
BROUGHT INTO JUVENILE COURT AT
A MUCH HIGHER RATE THAN A LOT
OF OTHERS AND NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY CAN GET THEIR NAME
THEIR GENDER STRAIGHT THROUGH
THIS PROCESS IT DOES NOT GET
RID OF THE NOTIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS IT DOES NOT GET
RID OF THE SHOWINGS. THAT THE
YOUTH NEEDS TO BRING TO THAT
COURT IT MERELY CHANGES THE
VENUE AND PROTECT THE PRIVACY
OF THAT YOUTH WITH THAT I ASKED
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER. SAYING NO DISCUSSION OF
BAY. OR CALL THE ROLL. ZERO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
A. ALL MEMBERS VOTE. THE DESIRE
TO VOTE. YEAH THE- CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I FIFTY TWO
NO SEVEN. THE MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEMS THIRTY ONE THIRTY TO
PASS OVER TO PASS RETAIN FILE
ITEM THIRTY THREE. HIS A. B.
SIX THIRTY SIX CORKERY ASSEMBLY
BILL SIX THIRTY SIX BY
pAND DEPENDENT ADULT ABUSE MR
MAIENSCHEIN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
RECENTLY THERE'S BEEN A LOT A
RISE IN ABUSE CASES INVOLVING
INDEPENDENT LIVING FACILITIES
PROVIDING SUB STANDARD CARE FOR
THE RESIDENTS MEMBERS MEMBERS.
THE RETENTION IS MAIENSCHEIN IN
SOME OF THESE FACILITIES THE
SUBSTANDARD CARE SO EXTREME
THEY CAN BE CONSIDERED ELDER
ABUSE BECAUSE INDEPENDENT
LIVING FACILITIES ARE
UNLICENSED IT IS OFTEN THE
LOCAL CODE COMPLIANCE ENTITIES
TO UNDERTAKE ENFORCEMENT AND
CLOSE SUBSTANDARD FACILITIES
THROUGH CLOSE CODE COMPLIANCE
CASES SB SIX THREE SIX WILL
PERMIT ADULT PROTECTIVE
SERVICES TO SHARE INFORMATION
WITH CODE ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
AND THEIR ATTORNEYS TO ADDRESS
SUB STANDARD CARE IN
INDEPENDENT LIVING FACILITIES.
THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. DAVIS
MAIENSCHEIN. C. NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. OUR
CLUB THE ROLE. THESE ARE VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF BOTH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. DESERVE VOTE.
WELL CLOTHES ARE ALL TIED UP I
SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES PASS RETAIN ON
FILE ITEMS THIRTY FOUR THREE
THIRTY NINE THIS BRINGS US TO
FILE ITEM FORTY. ACR FIFTY BY
MISS REYES CORKERY. ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION FIFTY BY
SIMPLY MEMORY AS AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO RAMADAN THIS RACE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS. TOMORROW WILL BE THE
FIRST DAY OF FASTING FOR
CALIFORNIA'S MUSLIM COMMUNITY
AND MUSLIMS AROUND THE WORLD AS
THEY BEGIN THE THIRTY DAYS OF
FASTING FOR THE MONTH OF
RAMADAN. ACR FIFTY IT KNOWLEDGE
IS THE MUSLIM HOLY MONTH OF
RAMADAN. AND EXPRESSES THE
LEGISLATURE'S RESPECT. TWO
MUSLIMS ACROSS CALIFORNIA AND
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD. RAMADAN
IS A TIME FOR REFLECTION AND
SPIRITUAL DISCIPLINE WHEN
MUSLIMS IS EXPRESS THEIR
DEVOTION TO FAITH FAMILY AND
SERVICE. THE MUSLIM AMERICAN
COMMUNITY CONTINUES TO BE A
PILLAR OF CALIFORNIA'S
DIVERSITY ENCOMPASSING NEARLY
EVERY ETHNIC GROUP OF OUR STATE.
AS THE MOST DIVERSE STATE IN
THE NATION ACR FIFTY IS
CRITICAL IN RESPECTING AND
CELEBRATING CALIFORNIA'S MUSLIM
COMMUNITY AND DEMONSTRATING OUR
COMMITMENT TO THE ONE MILLION
MUSLIM COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND
DEMONSTRATING OUR COMMITMENT.
WHO MAKE OUR ECONOMY SOCIAL
FABRIC AND DIVERSITY A STRENGTH
THE BENEFITS THE ENTIRE STATE.
THE MUSLIM COMMUNITY THROUGH
NUMEROUS CHARITIES IN
CALIFORNIA. HAVE BEEN IN THE
CENTRAL PART OF THE STATE'S
RESPONSE TO THE KOVITZ PANDEMIC
AS THEY'VE ORGANIZED FOOD
DISTRIBUTION EVENTS AND HOSTED
VACCINE CLINICS FOR VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. MEMBERS I ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT ON ACR FIFTY SO
THAT WE CAN COLLECTIVELY WISH
OUR MUSLIM FRIENDS AND
NEIGHBORS A BLESSED. RAMADAN.
NAME ADDRESS MISTER COOPER I
DON'T THINK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAMBHAR DEAL ON A BRING THIS
FORWARD- TODAY I RISE ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS TO RECOGNIZE THE
HOLY OBSERVANCE OF RAMADAN THIS
WHOLE TIME THE FASTING IS
PRACTICED AROUND THE WORLD BUT
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE OF DIFFERENT
RACES ON EVERY INHABITED
CONTINENT IN FACT THERE BEEN
AFTER AMERICANS OBSERVING
RAMADAN IN THE U. S. SINCE THE
FIRST LEYVA BOUGHT HERE. IS
ESTIMATED BETWEEN 10230% OF
AFRICANS BROUGHT TO THE US FOR
FROM MUSLIM BACKGROUNDS AND
THOSE BELIEFS AND TRADITIONS
WERE PASSED DOWN THROUGH
GENERATIONS TODAY MANY AFRICAN
AMERICAN FAMILIES CONTINUE TO
DRAW STRENGTH PEACE AND HOPE
THEIR MUSLIM FAITH THE V.
OBSERVANCE OF RAMADAN IS A
PHYSICAL ACT IS STRENGTHENS THE
SPIRIT OF THE BELIEVER IN THE
BOND WITHIN THE COMMUNITY AS
THE FAST IS BROKEN TOGETHER
UNFORTUNATELY LIKE MANY OF OUR
TREASURED HOLY OBSERVANCES
GATHERINGS THIS YEAR WILL BE
SMALLER THAN YEARS PAST HOWEVER
IS TO PRACTICING TIME HONORED
TRADITIONS A LOT OF A COMMUNITY
OF BELIEVERS AROUND THE WORLD.
THAT WE REALIZE HOW CONNECTED
WE ALL ARE THANK YOU FOR USING
THIS RESOLUTION. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. MISTER COOPER
MR GABRIEL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS IN
SUPPORT OF ACR FIFTY I WANT TO
THANK OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
SAMPOERNA DINO. THE MAJORITY
LEADER FOR ME FOR THIS
IMPORTANT RESOLUTION ON BEHALF
OF THE JEWISH CAUCUS. WANT TO
WISH A VERY SAFE AND A VERY
MEANINGFUL RAMADAN TO ALL OF
OUR MUSLIM FRIENDS AND
NEIGHBORS WE ARE SO FORTUNATE
TO HAVE SUCH A- VIBRANT MUSLIM
AMERICAN COMMUNITY HERE. IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
FORTUNATE TO HAVE A MUSLIM IMAM
THE LEADS US IN IN PRAYER AND
REFLECTION AT THE BEGINNING OF
OUR SESSION SO. I REMEMBER
BEING A LITTLE KID AND WHEN I
FIRST LEARNED ABOUT RAMADAN.
BEING IN AWE OF THIS SPIRITUAL
DISCIPLINE THAT IT MUST TAKE TO
FAST FOR SO MANY DAYS IN A ROW
AND- BEING AT SUCH ADMIRATION
OF THE DISCIPLINE AND
COMMITMENT TO FACE ON BEHALF OF
THE JEWISH CAUCUS. THE JEWISH
COMMUNITY I WANT TO WISH A
RAMADAN MUBARAK TO ALL OF OUR
MUSLIM FRIENDS AND NEIGHBORS.
AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE ON ACR FIFTY. THANK YOU
MISS GABRIEL. SEEING NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON THE
ITEM. MISCREANTS YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
ALSO WANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT OUR-
THE MOM YES SIR HAS ALSO BEEN
WORKING VERY DILIGENTLY IN
FEEDING OUR COMMUNITY FLOUT
THIS WEEKEND EIGHTEEN HUNDRED
FAMILIES. RECEIVED FREE FOOD
FROM THE TEMP FROM THE MOSQUE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT THE
FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. YEP IS ASKING
THE FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS CLERK WILL OPEN.
MEMBERS AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION. THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS. CO AUTHORS ON A HERE
FIFTY. THE CLERK WILL CLOSER
ROLE THERE SEVENTY CO AUTHORS
ADDED WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
YES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. MEMBERS THIS IS FILE
ITEM FORTY ONE AC ARE SIXTY
THREE BY MISTER SALAS THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION SIXTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SALAS RELATIVE
TO CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SAFETY
TELECOMMUNICATIONS
TELECOMMUNICATIONS WE- THIS
YOURSELVES. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT ACR SIXTY THREE WHICH
WILL DECLARE THE WEEK OF APRIL
ELEVENTH. TO APRIL SEVENTEENTH
OF CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SAFETY
TELE COMMUNICATORS WEEK OUR
STATE DEPENDS ON THE INCREDIBLE
WORK OF PUBLIC SAFETY
DISPATCHERS WHO ANSWER OVER
TWENTY SEVEN MILLION NINE ONE
ONE CALLS ANNUALLY AND ARE
OFTEN THE VERY FIRST RESPOND TO
A CRISIS. FROM COORDINATING
WILDFIRE RESPONSE RESPONDING TO
ACTIVE SHOOTER SITUATIONS ARE
COACHING SOMEONE THROUGH CPR
MANEUVERS DISPATCHERS ARE
HIGHLY SKILLED PUBLIC SERVANTS
WHO DEDICATE THEIR LIVES TO
HELPING OTHERS. LAST YEAR THIS
LEGISLATURE TOOK THE IMPORTANT
STEP OF FINALLY RECLASSIFYING
PUBLIC SAFETY TELE
COMMUNICATORS AS FIRST
RESPONDERS WITH PASSAGE OF
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN FORTY
FIVE. JOIN ME IN SUPPORTING OUR
CALIFORNIA BRAVE PUBLIC SAFETY
TELL COMMUNICATORS. WHO I'VE
HEARD PEOPLE DESCRIBE AS- OUR
DISPATCHERS ARE INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE NERVES OF STEEL. BUT
HEARTS OF GOLD I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE FIRST WILL
BE OPEN FOR CALL AUTHORS. THANK
YOU MISTER SALAS. SAYING NO
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION
MISTER CELLS AFTER THE FIRST
RUBIO FOR CO AUTHORS THE CLERK
WILL OVER THE ROLES. DOCTORS ON
THE RESOLUTION. COAUTHORS NICE
YEAR. SIXTY THREE. THIS IS FOR
CO AUTHORS. THE CLERK WELL
CLOSER ALL THERE ARE SEVENTY
ONE CO AUTHORS ADDED WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
HEARD ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY
AYE. AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY. YES
HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. FILE ITEM FORTY TWO H.
R. THIRTY TWO BY MR OF DONALD.
CALGARY HOUSE RESOLUTION THIRTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER O'DONNELL
RELATIVE TO CAMBODIAN GENOCIDE
MEMORIAL WEEK MISTER O'DONNELL.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS SOME REPS- I RISE TO
PRESENT HR THIRTY TWO WHICH
RECOGNIZES APRIL ELEVENTH
THROUGH APRIL SEVENTEENTH. AS
CAMBODIAN GENOCIDE MEMORIAL
WEEK. FROM APRIL SEVENTEENTH
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE TO
JANUARY SEVENTH NINETEEN
SEVENTY NINE THE COMMUTER RUSE
PERPETRATED ONE OF THE GREATEST
CRIMES OF THE TWENTIETH CENTURY.
NEARLY TWENTY MILLION PEOPLE
DIED UNDER THIS EXTREMIST RULE.
WHICH IMPOSED A RUTHLESS AGENDA
OF FORCED LABOR THOUGHT CONTROL
AND MASS ACTION EXECUTION UPON
CAMBODIA. AFTER THE OVERTHROW
OF THE COMMEMORATE REGIME IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE OVER ONE
HUNDRED AND FORTY THOUSAND
CAMBODIANS CAME TO THE UNITED
STATES AS REFUGEES. MY
COMMUNITY OF LONG BEACH IS
KNOWN AROUND THE WORLD IS HOME
TO THE LARGEST CAMBODIAN
COMMUNITY. OUTSIDE OF SOUTHEAST
ASIA. THE CAMBODIAN PEOPLE HAVE
DRAWN FROM THEIR CULTURAL
HISTORY TO REBUILD THEIR LIVES
AND COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE.
AND WE HAVE CONTRIBUTED GREATLY
FROM THIS. THE ENGAGEMENT AND
RISE OF THE CAMBODIAN COMMUNITY
AS EVIDENCED BY THE RECENT
ELECTION OF SULI SORROW TO THE
LONG BEACH CITY COUNCIL JUST
LAST YEAR. WHERE SHE GIVES
VOICE TO THE CAMBODIAN
COMMUNITY AND SERVES AS A ROLE
MODEL TO ALL. THIS CAMBODIAN
GENOCIDE MEMORIAL WE WILL HONOR
THE SURVIVORS AND THEIR
DESCENDANTS FOR THEIR COURAGE
IN CONTRIBUTIONS. TO OUR STATE
AND OUR COUNTRY. MAYBE REMEMBER
THE PAIN THE CAMBODIAN
COMMUNITY HAS SUFFERED THAT MAY
WE ACKNOWLEDGE THE GIFTS AND
SUCCESS THEY ARE BROUGHT TO OUR
FINE STATE. SO MARK STONE THANK
YOU. I ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THEY RICHARD AMISHA FLORA YOUR
READINESS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS- HR. AND FROM TWO THOUSAND
AND 1-220-002-0007 I HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF GOING OVER TO
CAMBODIA AT LEAST ONCE A YEAR
AND I CAN TELL YOU. THERE'S
BEEN NO BETTER PRIVILEGE OF MY
LIFE AND TO GET TO KNOW THE
CAMBODIAN COMMUNITY- WE HAVE A
STRONG COMMUTING COMMUTING IN
MY DISTRICT. BUT WHEN YOU GO
OVER THERE. AND YOU ACTUALLY
WALK THROUGH THE KILLING FIELDS.
WHEN YOU GO TO THE BOTTOM BALL.
THEY GO TO S. SEEN REAP.
POMPEIAN AND SEE WHERE THESE
MEN AND WOMEN WERE KILLED
BABIES MURDERED LITERALLY HELD
BY THE FEET HIT AGAINST TREES
BECAUSE THE CAMARO RUGE DIDN'T
WANT TO WASTE THE BULLET ON
THEM. THE ATROCITIES IS
INCREDIBLE IN THIS HAPPENED IN
THE SEVENTIES. FRIENDS IT
WASN'T THAT LONG AGO. WE CAN
NEVER REPEAT THIS AND WE IS A-
HUMANITY HAVE TO BE VIGILANT ON
WHAT'S GOING ON AROUND THE
WORLD BECAUSE THIS PARTICULAR
COMMUNITY HAS GONE THROUGH HELL
AND BACK AND I'M SO HAPPY TO
SEE THEM REBOUND IN A WAY THAT
THEY HAVE IT'S A PRIVILEGE TO
SUPPORT THIS TODAY. THANK YOU
MR FOR MR LOW. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I
RISE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS AND
THANK OUR COLLEAGUE. FROM LONG
BEACH I HAD THE DISTINCT.
EXPERIENCE TO TRAVEL TO
CAMBODIA WITH FORMER APEC
CAUCUS CHAIR DAS WILLIAMS ON
ANTI HUMAN TRAFFICKING MISSION.
AS WELL AS MAKING SURE THAT WE
REMEMBER THE WORLD HISTORY. WE
THANK THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM
LONG BEACH FOR BEING AN ALLY IN
ENSURING THAT WE DO NOT FORGET
OUR HISTORY RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. DAMOS LOW. THANK YOU
MEMBERS MISTER SPEAKER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR OF THE
CAMERA THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS JUST LAST WEEK WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT THE HOLOCAUST AND
ITS ATTEMPT TO EXTERMINATE THE
JEWISH PEOPLE ALTHOUGH WE SAY
NEVER AGAIN IT SEEMS THE URGE
TO GENOCIDE PERSISTS IT HAS
BEEN PERPETRATED AGAINST MANY
PEOPLE AGAINST MANY CULTURES.
TODAY WE COMMEMORATE THE
TERRIBLE LOSSES EXPERIENCED IN
CAMBODIA INFLICTED BY THE KHMER
ROUGE IN THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES
I THANK THE MEMBER FROM LONG
BEACH FOR BRINGING THIS MATTER
TO US IN HIS DISTRICT AND IN
AND IN MINE THERE ARE MANY MANY
PEOPLE WHO LEFT CAMBODIA TO
SETTLE IN CALIFORNIA THOSE
REFUGEES CAME HERE. HOPING FOR
PEACE AND ACCEPTANCE FOR THEM
AND FOR EVERY CULTURE THE COMES
YOU'RE SEEKING A HAVEN WHO WE
MUST REMEMBER WHAT HAPPENED IN
CAMBODIA THEY NEED THAT PEACE
THEY DESERVE THAT ACCEPTANCE
AND WE CAN PROVIDE IT CAMBODIAN
GENOCIDE MEMORIAL WEEK IS A
RECOGNITION OF THE CHAIRS
CAMBODIAN PEOPLE EXPERIENCED
DECADES AGO WE CAN ALSO USE
THIS OCCASION TO THINK ABOUT
OTHER ASYLUM SEEKERS NOW MAST
AT OUR BORDERS. OUR COUNTRY IS
NEVER TOO FULL OF REFUGEES IN
DIRE CIRCUMSTANCES WHEN THEIR
HOME COUNTRIES OFFER ONLY
OPPRESSION WE CAN OFFER HOPE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO JOIN ME
IN VOTING HI ONE HR THIRTY TWO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MISTER
DONALD YOU MAY CLOSE IF YOU
WISH. THAT'S WHEN I HAVE A
MISTER SPEAKER. MISTER DON
WOULD YOU LIKE COOPER. FIVE YES
I WAS A CO AUTHORS OF THE
RESOLUTION MR CALL THIS YEAR.
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING OVER THE
ROLE FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION CARPOOL OPEN THE
ROLE. MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS. THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
ON HR. THIRTY TWO. THE CLERK
WILL CLOSE RATHER SEVENTY TWO
CO AUTHORS ADDED WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A VOICE
VOTE. ON THE HOUSE RESOLUTION
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE
OPPOSED SAY DAY. YES HAVE IT
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. THIS
IS FILE ITEM FORTY THREE HR
THIRTY SEVEN FIVE ENSURE KALRA
THE CLERK WILL READ HOUSE
RESOLUTION THIRTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA RELATIVES
OF ICE HOCKEY. MISTER KALRA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AN HONOR TO PRESENT
HOUSE RESOLUTION THIRTY SEVEN
WHICH RECOGNIZES THIS YEAR'S BY
SAKE CELEBRATION ON TUESDAY
APRIL THIRTEENTH TOMORROW. THAT
ENCOURAGES CALIFORNIA TO TAKE
PART IN CELEBRATIONS PRIMARILY
ONLINE I HOPE ACROSS THE STATE.
AND ASIAN FESTIVAL GREAT
SIGNIFICANCE TO SIX HINDUS AND
BUDDHISTS AND MANY REGIONS OF
INDIA AND OTHER PARTS OF SOUTH
AND SOUTHEAST ASIA. BY SAKE IS
CELEBRATED ANNUALLY ON APRIL
THIRTEENTH OR FOURTEENTH ACROSS
THE WORLD THE BY MANY
CALIFORNIANS ARE SICK AND
INDIAN HERITAGE. FOUR SIX BY
SAKE HOLD SPECIAL RELIGIOUS AND
HISTORICAL SIGNIFICANCE BECAUSE
IT COMMEMORATES THE CREATION OF
KHALSA AND INITIATED THE FIVE
KAYS TRADITION OF THE CALLS SO
THAT CONTINUES TO BE THE BASIS
FOR THE UNIX LIKE IDENTITY. OR
BY SIX WHERE CASH ON PART HERE
PUNGA A WOODEN COMB KIND OF AN
IRON OR STEEL BRACELET WORN ON
THE WRIST GOOD UPON AN ARTICLE
OF FAITH TAKING THE FORM OF A
SWORD. AND COACHELLA SHORT
BRIDGES. H. R. THIRTY SEVEN IT
CALIFORNIA DEEP RESPECT FOR ALL
WHO OBSERVE AND CELEBRATE BY
SAKE IN THIS STATE. AND
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA. SEE NO
DISCUSSION OF A ON THE HOUSE
RESOLUTION MISTER KALRA WOULD
YOU LIKE TO AUTHORS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WITH THAT CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE THE HOME AUTHORS.
CO AUTHORS ON HR THIRTY SEVEN
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS. THIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS. CLARK WELL
CLOSE RATHER SEVENTY TWO CO
AUTHORS ADDED AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE EYES
HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. WE HAVE ONE ITEM THAT
IS ON CALL. I AM PREPARED TO
LIFT THE CALL. PREPARED TO LET
THE CALL ON FILE ITEM TWENTY
FOUR THIS IS AB FIVE OH THREE
BY MR STYLE AND THE CLERK WILL
POST. ALL MEMBERS VOTER WHO
WISH TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER
WHO WISH TO VOTE.
ALL THAT
RESERVATION OF A.
YEAH. CLOSE
ROLE. TELLURIDE'S THIRTY SIX
DOES TWENTY TWO THAT MEASURE
FAILS AND MR SNOWED NOTICES
RECONSIDERATION. MEMBERS I GET
A RETENTION. MEMBERS PLEASE
GIVE YOUR ATTENTION TO MR KOHLI
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER WE
HAVE A SPECIAL ANNOUNCEMENT MR
COOLEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN
THE REAR CHAMBER. FOR
COLLEAGUES. I ASK YOUR
ATTENTION FOR A FEW MINUTES. AS
WE HONOR A MEMBER OF THIS BODY.
IT'S BECOME COMMON TO NOTE THAT
AMERICA'S ARMED FORCES TODAY
ARE MOST OFTEN DEPLOYED. TO ARE
OFTEN CALLED ASYMMETRICAL
OPERATING ZONES. OR HAZARD TO
BROWN BUT SELDOM ARE PRESENT.
OR CELEBRATE SENT THEMSELVES AS
AN OBVIOUS PERIL. THIS IS
CHANGE OTHER MILITARY SEIZES
SPECIALIST COMBAT SOLDIERS
PROVIDE LOGISTICAL SUPPORT FOR
THE CLAMOR ENGINE ARMS ARE
ADEQUATELY SUPPLIED. THE JUST A
COOL DUDE IS A SECURE BASE ARE
AS SAFE AS IT COULD BE MADE TO
BE. BUT A SENSE OF SAFETY GETS
LEFTBEHIND IS TO LOSE ONE'S
DUTY. REQUIRES LEAVING A
FORTIFIED ENCLOSURE. THEN
COMBAT LOGISTICAL SPECIAL SPACE
MUCH GREATER PERSONAL HAZARD.
BECAUSE HOSTILE INDIVIDUALS
ACTIVELY HUNT TARGETS LIKE
SUPPLY CONVOYS. GIVEN THIS
EVOLUTION AND WARFARE
LOGISTICAL PLANNERS NOW REFER
TO SUPPLY CONVOYS AS COMBAT
LOGISTICAL PATROLS AND APPROACH
YOUR PLANNING COORDINATION
EXECUTION AS DELIBERATELY IS
ANY OTHER COMBAT OPERATIONS.
LAST FRIDAY APRIL NINTH WAS THE
THIRTEENTH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
DAY IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT. WHEN
OUR COLLEAGUE DEVON MATHIS
RECEIVED A COMBAT INJURY LED TO
HIS BEING AWARDED A PURPLE
HEART. ERICA'S OLDEST COMBAT
DECORATION. IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT R. SOMEONE MATHIS WAS
STARTED MATHIS OF THE ONE
THOUSAND ONE THIRTEEN
TRANSPORTATION COMPANY
CALIFORNIA BASED UNIT OF THE
UNITED STATES ARMY PROVIDED
LOGISTICS SUPPORT TO ARMY
COMBAT OPERATIONS. ON APRIL
NINTH TWO THOUSAND EIGHT- TWO
HUNDRED- TO FORTY HOURS.
SERGEANT MATT THIS WAS ON THE
ROLE OF THE LEAD VEHICLE
COMMANDER FOR COMBAT LOGISTICS
PATROL. THAT MEANS HIS VEHICLE
WAS THE FRONT UNIT. IN A
COMPACT LOGISTICS PATROL WHICH
HAD DEPARTED THE SECURED AREA
OF THE BAGHDAD INTERNATIONAL
AIRPORT. HELLO TWO FORTY AM HIS
VEHICLE WAS TRAVELING
SOUTHBOUND AT FORTY MILES PER
HOUR. AHEAD AT THE HEAD OF A
COLUMN OF VEHICLES MAINTAINING
A ONE HUNDRED METER INTERVAL
BETWEEN UNITS. SERGEANT
MASSIVELY VEHICLE IN CANADA
PRESSURE PLATE IMPROVISED
EXPLOSIVE DEVICE IN THEIR PATH.
IN A DESIGNATED ON THE DRIVER
SIDE. THE BLAST BROKE THE
VEHICLE'S FRONT AXLE DESTROYED
FORBIDS TIRES AND ULTIMATELY
DISABLED. AFTER THE BLAST SMALL
ARMS FIRE DIRECTED THE CONVOY
IN ITS VEHICLES AND SOLDIERS.
SERGEANT MADISON SUFFERED FROM
CONCUSSIONS FOR PREVIOUS IED
BLASTS BEFORE BUT THE
CONCUSSION HE RECEIVED. FROM
THE FORCE WHICH SHATTERED THE
TRUCK'S AXLE WAS DETERMINED
UPON EXAMINATION TO BE
ACCOMPLISHED. CONCUSSION WITH
RELATED INJURY TO HIS LEFT EAR
RESULTING IN HEARING LOSS.
STARTED MATHIS WAS WARNED THAT
ANOTHER IED BLAST PROPOSES TO.
IS THIS BODY HONORS ASUMA DEVON
MATHIS FOR LAST FRIDAY'S
ANNIVERSARY OF THE DATE HE WAS
COMBAT WOUNDED. I CONCLUDE BY
QUOTING THE MONUMENT NEAR
FOURTEENTH AND THEN IN CAPITOL
PARK. HONORING COMBAT WOUNDED
VETERANS. IT WAS DIRECTED A
DECADE AGO BY THE DEPARTMENT
CALIFORNIA MILITARY ORDER OF
THE PURPLE HEART CHAPTER THREE
FIVE IN STATES. YOU HAVE NEVER
LIVED. UNTIL YOU HAVE ALMOST
DIED. FOR THOSE WHO FOUGHT FOR
LIFE AS A FLAVOR THAT THE
PROTECTED WILL NEVER KNOW. I
THANK YOU FOR JOINING ME IN
THIS MOMENT TO HONOR CONRAD
DEVON MATHIS ASSEMBLY. YOU'LL.
DAVID COOLEY THANK YOU MISTER
MATHIS. SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS. TUESDAY APRIL
THIRTEENTH CHECK IN SESSION.
WEDNESDAY APRIL FOURTEENTH
CHECKING SESSION THURSDAY APRIL
FIFTEENTH THE FOUR SESSIONS AT
NINE AM. ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE PASSED TO
RETAIN ALL MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUED SEEING AND HEARING OR
FOR THE BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
IS REYES MOVES. THIS DAVEY
SECONDS. THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL THURSDAY APRIL
FIFTEENTH AT NINE AM IN THE
QUORUM CALL IS THAT THE.